[Musique]
messieurs dames bonsoir madame bonsoir
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview
nous sommes en direct Justine casselle
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement avec plaisir je suis
chercheuse et à INRIA Paris centre et à
carnigi Malan aux États-Unis je
travaille sur l'intelligence
artificielle les agents conversationnels
en particulier et j'ai peut-être la
particularité d'avoir dirigé l'équipe
qui a créé le premier chatpot incarné
avec un corps il y a 29
ans Cédric vilani bonsoir bonsoir est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter succ i
Villani mathématicien 50 ans professeur
à l'université Lyon 1 et à l'Intitut des
hautes études scientifiques à
bursurivette ancien parlementaire et
président de l'Office Parlementaire
scientifique et intéressé à un certain
nombre de sujets faisant intervenir la
vie publique la vie scientifique et
technologique les questions écologiques
en 2018 j'ai rendu au gouvernement un
rapport sur l'intelligence artificielle
qui a servi de base à la stratégie
nationale française dans l'intelligence
artificielle 5 ans après à un moment où
on parle plus d' que jamais c'est un bon
moment pour faire un petit bilan et
tâcher de voir ce qui arrive idée donc
ce soir comme vous avez pu le remarquer
on va parler intelligence artificielle
des répercussions des dangers des
avantages des qualités des angoisses des
uns et des autres et des envies des uns
et des autres et des fantasmes des uns
et des autres mais avant de commencer
sur ce sujet je voudrais poser la
question à
C tu a été rendre visite à Julian
Assange journaliste incarcéré en
Angleterre est-ce que tu peux nous en
parler je t'écoute c'était il y a un
mois quelque chose comme ça
j'étais rendre visite à julianassens
journaliste australien incarcéré dans la
prison très haute sécurité de
bellemarche à
Londres Julian est un journaliste il a
une formation de physicien il a un
rapport scientifique et geek aux
questions d'information à cur à cœur au
départ mais quelqu'un aussi qui a été
biberonné à la théorie de l'information
qui a bien en tête ce que c'est avit a
compris très tôt ce que c'était la
nouvelle donne de l'information dans le
monde numérique et a eu à cœur de mettre
en place un outil systémique Wikileak
pour augmenter la pression sur les
puissants révéler des secrets gênants
que l'opinion publique avait le droit de
savoir et pour apporter plus de pouvoir
aux simples citoyens plus de une vie
privée mieux couverte pour les citoyens
plus d'obligation de transparence pour
les puissants et en particulier c'est à
Wikileaks et Adriana Assange avec les
lanceurs d'alerte ed Snowden et lanceur
d'alerte Manning qu'on doit d'avoir
révélé des crimes de guerre de de en
particulier de l'armée américaine en
Irak en
Afghanistan l'espionnage de masse par la
ns le FBI qui a été développé à une
ampleur phénoménale
l'espionnage politique économique et
tout ce que vous voulez et ce sont des
choses qui n'ont pas plu au gouvernement
américain qui valent aujourd'hui à
Julian le journaliste le plus décoré du
21e siècle d'être traité exactement
comme un terroriste dans cette prison de
très haute sécurité dans une boîte de 6
m² 23h/ 24 et euh euh dans un dans dans
dans un contexte où tout est le moindre
de ces mouvements est surveillé et où
les États-Unis réclament son extradition
et où lui prépare un procès pour 175 ans
de prison alors premièrement au niveau
des droits humains c'est un cas patant
de violation tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
le rapporteur des Nations Unies sur les
mauvais traitements et la torture à
l'époque Nils melser avait fait un
rapport très clair indiquant que voilà
c'était quelque chose d'absolument
inacceptable deuxièmement par rapport à
la liberté de journalisme c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinairement grave tout ce
qu' a révélé Wikileaks est vrai personne
n'a été mis en danger par ces révélation
contrairement à ce que les autres
essayent de faire croire et sont des
informations Inter publiciqu et qui ont
influé sur la politique qui aurait pas
eu de rgpd par exemple en Europe s'il y
avait pas eu les révélations de Snowden
troisièmement au niveau géopolitique il
faut voir à quel point c'est sidérant
les États-Unis considèrent qu'ils ont le
droit de poursuivre un journaliste
australien pour des choses qu'il a
effectué en Europe de le juger sur sol
américain et de choisir sa peine c'est
quelque chose qui est tellement
monstrueux tellement qui serait un
précédent tellement incroyable que ça ça
ça dépasse l'entendement et donc c'était
mon devoir d'aller voir Jan assassange
en soutien en prison lui apporter du
soutien psychologique un peu de
conversation et de contribuer à rendre
visible son sort qui nous concerne tous
et
toutes Justine en tant qu'ancienne
citoyenne américaine parce que tu es
naturalisée
française qu'est-ce que ça te fait
d'entendre
ça alors en BRAF j'ai choisi de vivre en
France
voilà
j'ai bénéficier d'une éducation
formidable aux
États-Unis en tant que jeune personne ou
mes parents m'ont envoyé dans une école
sans notes et sans rang
j'aurais pas fini euh l'école sans ça ça
m'a permis de faire ce qui me
passionnait et pas ce que je détestais
enfin bon c'est une bonne chose et une
mauvaise chose pour un enfant j'ai eu un
doctorat à l'Université de Chicago euh
qui était très strict et qui m'a
beaucoup appris mais en choisissant où
vivre cette partie de ma vie enfin je
fais les allés-retours depuis l'âge de
19 ans j'ai fait une licence de l
moderne à
besonangac on le passe bonjour oui voilà
besang plutôt
et et à un moment je me suis dit je me
vois plus dans les États-Unis je me vois
plus dans ce que je vois réfléter maté
dans les journaux et donc j'ai choisi de
venir ici vivre de façon permanente
bienvenue en France
merci euh donc parlons un peu c'est un
sujet ultra important le journalisme
d'investigation pour les populations
pour la démocratie et et on fera on
refera une émission dédiée sur ce
sujet-là on activera notre réseau pour
faire un peu de bruit d'une façon
beaucoup plus perforant
perforant que reporter sans frontières
qui organise des carmesses et qui se
fait refouler à la porte de la prison
on va parler d'intelligence
artificielle Justine qu'est-ce que tu
peux me dire sur le fait que l'armée
israélienne utilise une intelligence
artificielle pour faire des frappes
est-ce que tu en as entendu parler
est-ce que tu as entendu parler avant
des robots autonomes à action létal sur
les gardes frontières que tu peut avoir
en
Asie côté coréen je
dirais toi en tant que chercheuse le
fait qu'il y a une militarisation d'une
technologie
réaction létale qu'est-ce que ça te fait
parle-moi dis-moi le fond de ta
pensée benah encore une réponse qui peut
peut-être paraître à côté mais j'ai vu
le film
openheimer lorsqu'il est sorti et j'ai
sangloté tout le
long j'ai été avec une amie qui n'a pas
compris pourquoi ça m'a tellement
attristé euh à la fin je lui ai dit je
nous vois
là-dedans je vois ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui dans ce qui est arrivé à
openheimer de plusieurs points de vue
d'abord il faut dire que mon grand-père
a travaillé sur la bombe atomique sans
savoir ce que c'était il était à tenisy
et non pas en nouvel-mexique
et à la fin on lui a demandé sur quoi il
travaillait il paraît qu'il a dit à mon
père qui était enfant qui travaillait
sur euh la plus grande lumière qui soit
donc vraiment il savait pas ce que
c'était mais il a refusé d'en parler à
la fin de sa
vie chez
openheimer j'ai vu la passion d'un
chercheur né et je le ressens aussi je
veux aller au a si loin que possible au
même temps je suis
activiste jusqu'aux
os quand j'ai été naturalisé il a fallu
que je demande mon dossier FBI j'étais
contente j'étais sûr que j'allais avoir
un épais dossier FBI parce que surtout
quand j'étais ad j'étais assez activiste
je me retrouvais à Washington pas mal et
j'ai été très déçu lors que j'ai reçu
comme retour
on ne trouve pas de dossier au nom de
Justine
cassal
openheimer a poursuivi la science et il
pensait que ça allait aider le
monde jusqu'à un certain point et puis
il s'est rendu compte ce qui se passait
et à ce moment-là je pense qu'il a plus
pu faire marche
arrière j'ai j'ai peur enfin je je crois
beaucoup dans les bénéfices de
l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai commencé à travailler
là-dedans parce que je
m'intéressais à la capacité des
personnes de nouer une relation avec
autrui et l'importance de ces liens et
pour moi tout au début l'intelligence
artificielle a servi d'outil pour mieux
comprendre l'humain et les relations
humaines et puis j'ai trouvé des moyens
d'utiliser la l'intelligence
artificielle pour créer des applis qui
aidaient les enfants défavorisés qui
parlent des dialectes des quartiers ce
qu'on appelle en France des dialectes
des quartiers l'argot
ou enfin pas l'argot des dialectes enfin
bon le langage vernaculaire local c'est
ça voilà
exactement mais ça peut être
militarisé mais tout outil peut être
militarisé
je dis parfois que lors que on me dit
que ce que je fais peut tuer que dans
les salles de classe les enfants pas mal
utilisent leur
crayant voilà pour
essayer de se tuer qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je vais être honnête je ne sais pas
j'abandonnerai pas la voix de la science
à cause des peurs et des craintes et des
fantasmes des citoyens vis-à-vis des
nouvelles
technologies et il y a 10 ans j'ai
commencé à lire l'histoire moi je ça m'a
jamais intéressé mais il y a 10 beaucoup
d'Américains d'ailleurs oui ben oui
c'est vrai et moi mon école
expérimentale on a fait qu'un cours
d'histoire et c'était l'histoire de
l'Afrique donc j'ai jamais fait
d'histoire mais j'ai commencé à
réfléchir histoire des technologies et
ce que j'ai appris c'est que il y a
toujours ce qu'on appelle une panique
morale vis-à-vis des nouvelles
technologies j'ai écrit des articles
là-dessus j'ai écrit un article un long
article sur les craintes vis-à-vis des
filles en ligne il y a 10 ans ou 12 ans
où on disait qu'il fallait interdire aux
filles de passer du temps en ligne parce
que c'était dangereux pour elle on
commence toujours
avec un amour de ce qui est nouveau et
ça s'ensuit d'une peur bleu mais pour
moi ces peurs c'est des peurs de ce que
nous devenons c'est pas vraiment la peur
des technologie et je pense que c'est le
cas avec l'intelligence artificielle ce
qui nous effraye c'est le fait
que on abandonne les liens humains on
abandonne l'espoir
dans
l'humanité Cédric avant de te redonner
la parole je vais reposer une question à
Justine
entre l'époque du projet Manathan de ton
papa et maintenant de ton grand-père
pardon pardon je suis une très vieille
personne pe tu es bien conservé dis
donc c'est l'effet de la France oui
voilà c'est le 20 commencez pas
entre l'époque du projet manatan et
maintenant certes à l'époque du projet
manatan il y avait la guerre avec le
Japon il y avait la guerre avec les
nazis avant il y avait tout ça on avait
connu le nazisme on avait connu
maintenant qu'on a plus de maturité
concernant la consommation des
ressources l'accession aux ressources le
fait que il y a un protectionnisme qui
est en train de monter de plus en plus à
cause de l'accession au ressources pour
maintenir une classe politique dominante
dans chaque pays parce que sans
ressources les politiques
sont difficilement maintenables en
France on a une expression qui dit quand
il n'y a plus de foin dans les ratelier
les chevaux se battent donc la maturité
que nous avons autour de de de cette
table de ce tapis de ce bou de
moquette on voit bien que les tensions
augmentent que la militarisation de ce
type de projet avec cette fonction
exponentielle capable de perforer des
strates de nos sociétés de surveiller
notre population de surveiller nos
démocraties c'est pas donner des lames
de rasoir à des
singes est-ce qu'un scientifique quand
il réalise
l'immaturité la paresse
intellectuelle de sa caste politique
est-ce que le
scientifique par amour pour l'humanité
doit arrêter de fournir des lames de
rasoir à des singes
pour moi le scientifique doit surtout
continuer et trouver et pousser et et
convaincre ces étudiants de pousser les
bonnes choses qu'on peut faire avec ces
technologies pour moi enfin bon Cédric
n'est peut-être pas d'accord mais pour
moi il faut il faut pas s'arrêter il
faut montrer aux jeunes chercheurs le
bonheur d'utiliser ces technologies pour
le bon il faut il faut regarder l'état
de l'éducation parce que c'est pas que
les technologies qui nous désolent
aujourd'hui il y a plein d'autres choses
qui nous désolent moi je regarde l'état
de l'éducation euh dans plusieurs pays
euh disons plusieurs pays et ça me
désole et je vois les les belles choses
qu'on peut faire avec l'intelligence
artificielle pour les les étudiants
enfin j'espère qu'on va revenir
là-dessus parce que j'ai une perspective
un pe tu fais ce que tu veux tu tu tu
prends la parole tu continues ton sujet
si je peux bien sûr ok euh je commence
toujours mes conférences en ce moment
avec une image
d'élèves chacacun devant un ordi et je
dis l'avenir donc sur cette image c'est
marqué l'avenir de
l'éducation deuxè
diapo rayure rouge à travers cette image
dystopie de
l'éducation donc moi je pense que enfin
c'est ce que je fais j'utilise l'IA
pour pour comprendre comment les enfants
et les jeunes personnes lient la
connivance avec autrui les bénéic de la
connivance pour la santé et pour
l'éducation et puis à la base de mes
études d'enfant enfant jeune jeune je
crée des technologies qui permettent aux
jeunes de lier la connivance et avec les
machines et avec autrui donc je
m'arrêterai pas mais je passe beaucoup
de temps beaucoup trop de temps en ce
moment vis-à-vis de du temps que je
passe dans mon Labau à parler aux
instits aux politiciens au aux
industriels de comment utiliser cette
technologie pour de Ban j'ai été invité
cette année à Davos euh ça sera ma 9e la
9e fois que je parle à Davos et j'ai
l'intention de diriger la conversation
d'essayer de faire de mon mieux de
pointer ce qu'il faut faire les
utilisations qui qui nous font Fiè de ce
qu'on fait au lieu de donner des lames
de rasoir au
singes est-ce que tu donnes la parole à
Cédric
Cédric je vais faire quelques
commentaires sur ce qu'a dit Justine et
d'abord le sujet central la
responsabilité du scientifique par
rapport à l'utilisation de ces
inventions il est majeur et indémélable
j'ai fait tout un bouquin dessus une
bande dessinée avec le dessinateur
Edmond Baudouin s'appelle les RVER
lunaire ça c'est ancré dans la seconde
guerre mondiale et le principe c'est que
je mets en scène dans quatre chapitres à
chaque fois un moment très émotif de
leur vie quatre personnes qui ont joué
un rôle majeur sur la question
innovation développement dans la dans la
seconde guerre mondiale le premier c'est
Heisenberg qui a joué un rôle majeur en
creux parce qu'il a juste échoué à
dirigé le programme nucléaire allemand
et on le voit juste après l'explosion du
6 août
1945 avec d'autres scientifiques
allemands qui sont tous emprisonnés à
farm Hall à l'époque où les les alliés
les espionnent pour savoir exactement ce
qu'il SAV et ils sont très étonnés de
découvrir que ils étaient allés nulle
part en matière de de de de projet
atomique le deuxième c'estan Ting qu'on
voit en 1954 la veille de son suicide le
le trème c'est lo silard physicien
hongrois qui a joué un rôle majeur dans
la constructionatomique qui est sour
présenté dans le film openheimer c'est
l'une des rares reproches que j'ai à
faire sur ce sur ce film sous présenté
sous représenté oui son rôle son vrai
rôle a été beaucoup plus important que
ce qui est présenté dans le film silard
a été le premier à avoir l'inttuition de
ce que ser une réaction en chaîne en
1933 ou 33 je crois a a été convaincu
que le monde allait à sa perte parce que
les Allemands seraient les premiers à
développer la bombe atomique à remuer
ciel et terre pour que le projet
Manhattan se fasse a tenu la main
Einstein pour écrire la fameuse lettre
qu'il a écrite pour le développement du
du Projet Manhattan silard est devenu
ensuite un quand il a compris que la
bombe atomique serait utilisée non pas
contre les Allemands mais contre les
Japonais a été c'est toute sa sa vie qui
était qui était ruiné est devenu plus
tard un important militant pacifiste les
conférences pugw pour le le désarmement
et les choses comme ça personnage de
roman on le voit je le représente en
1960 quand il euh met le né dans son
propre traitement pour son cancer et il
demande au médecins d'augmenter très
sensiblement les doses de radioactivité
qu'il va subir c'est un vrai personnage
de roman très méconnu son son
autobiographie s'appelle genus in the
shadow euh avec toute cette ce destin
incroyable il à la T et le 4e c'est Yuk
daouding qui était le général qui a joué
un rôle clé dans la bataille de
d'Angleterre pour empêcher que les les
les les Américains que les les nazis
envahissent la GrandeBretagne et lui je
le montre en 1968 au moment où il est il
y a un film qui est tourné dans lequel
il voit Laurent Soliver qui joue son son
propre rôle en tout cas et et mes quatre
personnages je l'ai fait avec leur débat
intérieur débattre à chaque fois avec
eux ou avec les autres sur ce thème
c'est quoi notre responsabilité
là-dedans euh est-ce qu'il faut Ess
contrôler le le l'invention est-ce que
c'est le bien commun c'est un problème
qui est à la fois majeur et indémêlable
et dans le cas de la bombe atomique faut
bien se rappeler que ils étaient
persuadés le top niveau que si eux ne le
faisaient pas les Allemands les nazis
allaient le faire et ça serait une une
catastrophe encore supérieure une grande
différence alors d'abord avant de parler
de la grande différence je voudrais
ajouter que l'expérience montre que très
souvent les premières applications qu'on
trouve à de nouvelles théories
mathématique
ou physique fondamental quand on trouve
des applications elles sont du côté
militaire compris dans les sujets que
j'ai travaillé moi comme transport
optimalarent vient du militaire pas que
l'argent vient du militaire mais
aussi il y a une pu toujours il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire des des des
compétences qui sont mises par les États
du côté du côté militaire qui très tôt
repère ce qui peut servir avec toute la
pression par exemple le tout premier
système de télécommunication au monde
j'ai bossé là-dessus pour une podcast
France Culture c'était quand l'ingénieur
Claude chap met en place un système de
sémaphore pour aider la France à à
survivre pendant la guerre en 1780 C en
93 je crois au moment où c'était la la
grande guerre ou dans un sujet que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé fait une partie de ma
carrière làdessus le transport
optimal le le père fondateur c'est
Gaspar Monge les premières réalisations
de Gaspar Monge dans les années à la fin
du 8e siècle c'était la géométrie euh
descriptive et son invention avait été
jugée tellement importante pour décrire
des des plans trois dimensions faire des
relevés que la l'armée laav l'armée
Royal l'avait classé secret défense
c'était interdit d'exposer la géométrie
descriptive à quiconque était pas un
officier de de de rang suffisant bon
donc ces applications elles sont
toujours là et c'est quelque chose avec
quoi on doit on doit vivre bien souvent
Léo feré disait Léo feré chantait dans
sa chanson yanamar monsieur
Einstein croyant monsieur Einstein loin
des canons croyant travailler pour lui
seul a découvert des équations qui vont
nous tomber sur la
gueule je peux parler vas-y
vas-y qu'est-ce qu'ors pardon excuse-moi
excuse-moi te je t'en prie il y a une
grosse différence maintenant entre le
projet manatan bien souvent on voit les
gens qui font le parallèle comme jusine
vient le faire et qui qui qui demande
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui qui
vient là dans le développement de l tel
qui sont maintenant le projet manatan
est-ce qu'il a des des des parallèles il
y a des parallèles mais il y a une
grosse différence projet manattan
c'était un projet énorme qui aurait pas
pu se faire sans un management
extrêmement rigoureux fait par
openheimer et si l'une des personnes du
top management avait dit on se retire le
projet pouvait pas se faire tandis
queaujourd'hui pour l' quelqu'un dit le
projet sortir ben ça change rien il y en
a partout c'est diffus il y a des
dizaines de labo à travers le monde qui
sont capablees de continuer développer
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus inéluctable le
développement de l'a que l'était le
développement du projet
Manhattan très bon point ouiou Léo
Ferret ce qui va nous tomber sur la
gueule qu'est-ce qui va nous tomber sur
la gueule quels sont les risques d'une
militarisation à l'outrance de
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
je vous donne un cas de figure
complètement faisons une expérience de
pensée tous ensemble admettons que nos
gouvernements occidentaux issus d'une
société
thermo-industrielle en sevrage
énergétique avec une population tombant
vers le
populisme poussant des gens vers le
populisme avec des services public à un
système éducatif en effondrement en
collap
quand cette expérience de pensée
imaginez-vous qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire avec de l'intelligence
artificielle on pourrait cornaquer tu
comprends
cornaquer est-ce qu'on
pourrait mettre sous camiso
numérique avec des pics sur les côtés
pour pouvoir encadrer notre population
j'ai pas
terminé est-ce que on pourrait
surveiller détecter des des
comportements détecter précocément des
gens qui pourraient devenir
journalistes
procureurs même libre penseurs par leur
lecture par leur cte de bibliothèque
leur historique internet leur façon de
marcher leur façon leur rythme cardiaque
face à une émotion qu'il pourraient
recevoir sur un ordinateur est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir une guerre cognitive
analysé tellement finement qu'on
pourrait détecter les proch leader qui
mettrait en doute ou mettre en question
des gouvernements autoritaires donc
quels sont les risque qui pourrait nous
tomber sur la tête avec de
l'intelligence
artificielle n'ayant pas un encadrement
suffisamment démocratique pour maintenir
une autonomie de
pensée je vous écoute qui veut prendre
la
parole tentation de la surveillance de
masse est forte pour un pouvoir
incontestablement et déjà du point de
vue du côté des États autoritaires je
parle pas des démocrati tu parles de des
États-Unis alors les États-Unis sont une
démocratie
malade mais je veux dire la Russie la
Chine d'autres États ont mis en œuvre
ces dernières années de façon très
efficace de
l'algorithmique pour renforcer leur
pouvoir de façon forte d'une part en
attaquant à coup de cyberattaque massive
et de propagande l A est très efficace
pour la propagande les autres pays et
vraiment en avant on attaque les
hôpitaux on attaque les institutions met
le bazar les jours d'élection
déstabilise à n'importe quelle échéance
démocratique les autres on met toutes
sortes de de narratifs et tout ça ça il
sa faire et deuxièmement en interne pour
vérifier encadrer sur surveillé la Chine
étant peut-être le pays qui a le
plus mis les moyens sur ce genre de
choses maintenant ce qui est dérangeant
c'est quand on voit à quel point tout à
l'heure je par aux États-Unis comme
d'une démocratie malade mais quand la
tentation est arrivée de la surveillance
numérique ils sont allés à fond et à
coup sûr c'est pas les seuls qui auront
cette tentation et on verra comment ils
résisteront ou
pas au Père
Noël le Père
Noël existe quand j'ai travaillé pour
sur les 400 ans de bless Pascal et ben
il y a un moment où il a une grande
controverse sur l'existence du vide avec
le Père Noël qui était un père religieux
qui lui expliquait que ses expérience
sur le vide elle pouvait pas marcher
parce que comme Aristote avait démontré
le vide n'existait pas le Père Noël en
l'occurrence se plantait celui-là il
existe l'autre je crois pas qu'il existe
le petit pe bonhomme rouge et tout
ça
Justine je ne suis pas futuriste et je
refuse de l'être mais par contre les
probabilités ça ça te
parle il y a un nombre
inombrable pour ainsi dire de mauvaises
avenirs
de de mauvaises
utilisation mais
et vous pouvez m'appeler naïve et je le
suis sûrement non on fera pas ça
d'accord je le ferai moi-même je je suis
antirégulation et pro
éducation j'ai eu l'honneur de faire
partie du Conseil National du Numérique
un groupe de 15 à peu près 15 personnes
de disciplines différentes des
sociologues des philosophes des prêtres
et notre premier papier était donc on a
on a fait une série de de White Paper en
français dans le texte et le premier
était sur le numérique et les savoirs et
on a clamé pour une éducation du
numérique qui ne s'arrête pas comme on
voit aujourd'hui comme des lessons de
programmation ce qui vraiment est triste
mais une éducation qui comprend
l'économique le soci sociologique la
sociologie l'économie
l'anthropologie
l'éducation la philosophie des
technologies dans leur ensemble pour que
nous créons des générations qui
réfléchissent avant de d'avancer dans le
mauvais
sens quelle année ça c'était il y a 2
ans c'est un
échec trop tôt trop tôt pour dire ouais
c'est trop tôt pour dire et puis j'ai
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec je dis tu
sais pourquoi je dis c'est un échec non
dis-moi parce que c'est beaucoup trop
tard ah bah trop tard et trop tôt parce
que bah je vois la Floride aux
États-Unis où l'éducation tombe à l'eau
enfin ça me fait en tant que prof en
tant que personne qui adore en enseigner
ça me fait de la peine de voir des des
écoles en en
2023 interdire les livres sur les
stéréotypes du genre sur le racisme euh
sur les
transgenres c'est j'ai physiquement mal
et en
France ça fait pas longtemps que je suis
là et dans cette courte période je ne
vois que des changements dans
l'éducation nationale tous les quelques
mois plus de math moins de
math plus d'art plastique pas assez de
temps pour les arts plastiques et ça
aussi ça me désole donc c'est trop tard
mais c'est surtout pas
écouter parce que on essaie d'avancer un
petit peu
aveuglement on on essaie de
restreindre ce que connaissent nos
élèves au lieu de leur ouvrir les yeux
et je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut j'is
tout de suite attends et tu tu suis un
peu la Suède la Suède c'est un beau pays
hein ouais c'est un beau pay ils
viennent ils viennent de
de remettre au goût du jour le fait de
blasphémer un livre ça devient interdit
un livre religieux déchirer une page
d'un livre religieux et devient interdit
qu'est-ce que tu en penses en fait c'est
le Danemark pardonemar c'est aussi très
joli oui je vous conseille d'ailleurs
Christiania j'ai été ou ça m'étonne
pas qu'on y
ailleem il faut y aller au
printemps comment tu veux que je sois
sérieux possible Justine quand tu vois
le le retour du du
blasphème ça devient interdit en tant
que prof qu'est-ce que tu en penses le
problème c'est la définition du
blasphème déchirer un livre religieux
ouais je comprend l'intention je sais
pas si vous avez suivi mais aux
États-Unis il y a quelques jours il y a
TR ou 4 jours les républicains ont
demandé au au présidents de trois
grandes fac mit Harvard université de
Pennsylvanie voilà de Pen et de parler
de ce qu' interdisait c un piège c'était
totalement un piège et ces pauvres
présidents d'université qui lutte pour
savoir où est la quand même un piège
simple à
répondre non je pense pas que c'était
simple à répondre non je pense pas que
c'était aussi simple comme la question
de blasphémille n'est pas simple parce
que le fait le fait de dire euh inciter
inciter euh au ravage du peuple juif
est-ce que ça viole votre code de
conduite de d'université a pas posé
comme ça elle a posé comment elle a dit
est-ce que les actes contre les Juifs
enfin un truc très vague qui pourrait
être euh compris comme appeler euh la la
mort de tous les juifs ou euh dire du
mal du peuple juif ou euh dire du bien
du peuple palestinien c'était assez
vague pour que on voyait lutter avec la
question c'est présidente c'était trois
femmes et ne pas savoir comment répondre
et je suis avec elle en fait je sais pas
comment répondre non plus je ne sais pas
comment définir la blasphémie parce que
si on définit la la blasphimie
aujourd'hui comme déchirant une page
d'un livre religieux là je veux bien
c'est pas ça qui va changer ce qui va
changer c'est la définition de la
blasphémie et ça ça ouvre la porte à de
mauvaises choses aussi euh qu'à de de
bon Bones actes Cédric pendant que tu
parles j'ai mon technicien qui va
remettre un peu le micro de Justine mais
tu t'inquiète pas tu peux continuer à
parler avec moi euh
d'abord
je j'avais pas en tête ces déformations
et je serais curieux de regarder
exactement comment ça s'est passé c'est
quelque chose que j'ai vu de près que à
certaines occasions j'ai vécu
douloureusement quand on te pose une
question tu fais une réponse et puis sur
le tweet qui va on change un mot dans la
question un mot dans la réponse et tout
de suite ça devient quelque chose de
grave choquant voilà c'est des c'est
redoutable ce genre de chos très dur de
voir comment contrer je voudrais dire
des choses sur sur l'enseignement c'est
vrai que on a tous les problèmes sur
toutes les questions sur l'enseignement
sur le secondaire sur le primaire toutes
les questions sur la recherche et et
puis la les annonces compliquées et
anxiogènes du président Macron hier sur
les questions universitaires et de
recherche je vais dire quand même
quelque chose de positif là-dedans après
après mon après mon la fin de mon mandat
parlementaire je me suis remis à faire
des cours à
l'université qu'est-ce que ça a fait du
bien à ma santé
mentale avoir en face de soi des
étudiants motivés faisant
systématiquement plus que ce que je leur
demandais intéressé à approfondir enfin
cidé vraiment d'avoir un projet qu'on
puisse faire ensemble sans sans
quelqu'un qui cherche à te piéger à à te
faire un crooc en jambe ici et là ça
faisait vraiment beaucoup de bien et des
cours des des cours intéressants que
j'ai voulu aussi en partie nourrie de ou
des cours mathématiques bien sûr mais
ouvert sur des questions extérieur par
exemple mathématiqu des
écosystèmes très important
l'enseignement uite je vais rebondir sur
ce que dit Justine par rapport à
l'éducation éducation c'est magique au
sens où ça résout tellement tellement de
choses y compris des questions de et ça
ça c'est l'éducation des femmes dans le
monde ce sont les les les meilleures
politiques natalistes qui soit et ce
genre de choses Jea la meilleure
politique de contraception absolument
oui enfin politique de nataliste au sens
à la baisse ça que je vou ça pororte des
bénéfices économiques aussi plus les
bénéfices économiques dans le dernier
dans le rapport du Club de Rome celui
qui a été fait là 50 ans après le
rapport historique MOS de 1972 dernier
rapport du Club de Rome euh euh en
capacitation unowment des femmes
éducation des femmes c'est un des un des
axes centraux du plan pour pour pour
sauver le monde si je puis dire
maintenant ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
est pas quelque chose de de léger de
léger mais ce qui est un but respectable
aussi alors le
le maintenant un les changements dans
l'éducation ils sont d'habitude
terriblement lents ça demande des
efforts soutenus sur la durée parce
qu'il s'agit d'agir sur la formation sur
le recrutement des enseignants sur des
pratiques culturelles de en France on a
un problème majeur notre problème numéro
1 dans l'éducation c'est le fait c'est
le statut de nos
enseignants statut avec l'argent tout
simplement d'une part statut immatériel
de la société d'autre part l'image que
c'est rendu et de pas se faire marcher
dessus par la hiérarchie par les parents
d'élèves par par qui sait quoi très
important les comparaisons
internationales montrent que les
systèmes qui marchent le mieux c'est
avant tout les systèmes dans lesquels
les enseignants sont le plus respectés
valorisés par la société à la finis en
terme de salaire et en terme de de
respect et puis c'est aussi des systèmes
dans lesquels il y a une synergie entre
la sphère parentale et la sphère de
l'enseignement donc c'est un problème de
ressources humaines avant tout plus que
la question de combien d'heures de ceci
combien d'heures de cela et quand on
arrive à avoir les bonnes conditions et
les les enseignants qui sont fiers
motivés sont prêts à faire des choses
parfois bluffantes y compris sur les
questions numériques quand chat GPT est
arrivé on se disait comment faire de
l'éducation autant de chatpt on sera
plus distingué le vrai du faux et cetera
il y a des il y a des profs qui ont
trouvé comment utiliser chat GPT pour
nouvelles activités voici un exemple qui
m'avait fasciné pour un prof de je sais
plus si c'était fin de primaire ou début
de collège en tout cas pour des pour des
petits distribu des cartes postales au
gamins on les met face à un promp de de
de D ou un truc équivalent qui te qui te
génre imag pour ceux qui ne savent pas
prompte un petit dialogue qui s'engage
avec un petit signe souvent un signe
supérieur qui dit c'est à toi de parler
et tu mets ta tu mets ta commande dessus
pour dialoguer avec le l'algorithme et
donc dans dans ces programmes de type
d'Ali tu indiques ce que tu veux voir tu
le mets en français je veux voir euh Sky
avec un des oreilles de lapin sur la
tête ou quelque chose comme ça et puis
te le Christiania c'était fort quand
même hein ou ouais bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr faut pas qu'on promte
chatdp tout seul tous les deux voilà qui
sait ce qu'on pourra faire ensemble avec
on va voir ça en tout cas le but de de
la de l'action en classe c'est que les
gamins il ils doivent trouver le bon
prompte les bonnes instructions qui
permettent à wali de reproduire aussi
fidèlement que possible la carte poale
qu'ils ont en face où tu vois que
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à déterminer ce
qui dans l'image est important ou pas
faire un bon travail de description
analytique mais aussi avoir les bons
mots de vocabulaire pour décrire ce que
tu vois si un château tu vas parler du
pont leev tu vas parler des douves tu
vas parler des des des des meurtrières
ou qui sais quoi créneaux des
créneaux donjon je sais pas et tout ça
ça tout ça ça participe à le le leur
permettre aussi alors on peut imaginer
que le prof se déplace mais les élèves
pevent bosser sur le chemin de ronde ou
tu aimes bien F la métaphore ouais et et
et il fait une évaluation de ces fidèles
troupe que sont les élèves mais en tout
cas c'est une façon d'utiliser ce type
de d'intelligence artificielle
générative on verra après on parlera un
peu plus en détail de de quel type d'
pour aider les élèves à développer leur
vocabulaire leur capacité d'analyse bref
des qualités humaines on est dans un
exemple d'outil convivial comme disait
Ivan un outil qui permet de développer t
capacité humaine et c'est un excellent
exemple chatpt et l'éducation parce que
exactement le parcours dont on parlais
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire une peur
bleue que ça allait nous détruire une
journaliste
d'un d'un journal très connu chif
magazine non aux États-Unis peut-être le
plus lu aux États-Unis m'a contacté et
elle a dit dans son mail est-ce que le
chat GPT ne va pas détruire
l'enfance j'adore quand les journalistes
savent déjà la morale de l'histoire
c'est souvent comme ça ouais c'est ouais
ouais c'est pas mal souvent comme ça
comm Wikipédia ils aiment bien et j'ai
dit non et elle a dit ben si chat GPT ça
va détruire l'éducation et détruire
l'enfance ça va dire on se demande
pourquoi elle t'interview si elle oui
oui et ben en fait elle n'a utilisé une
petit un petit bout de phrase de ma part
parce qu'elle aimait vraiment pas je lui
ai écrit deux pages elle a dit c'est
dangereux parce que chat GPT pourrait
dire je t'aime aux enfants et les
enfants vont confondre chat JPT avec une
vraie personne donc j'ai fait un peu de
recherche j'ai trouvé 10 poupées les
plus aimés des parents américains qui
disent je t'aime aux enfants et qui sont
le plus acheté par des parents
américains je lui ai fait remarquer que
aucun enfant n'a confondu une poupée
avec une vraie personne enfin s'il y a
peut-être des enfant à
trouble enfin oui voilà mais mais les
enfants typiques comme on dit n'ont
jamais fait cette confusion les enfant
neurotypiquesur oui je je disais plutôt
typique pour comprendre toutes sortes de
typicités les enfants ne typique aussi
finin comme exemple type
et la peur qui a accompagné
chatpt dans le monde de l'éducation
était incroyable enfin vraiment on ne
voyait que ça et il n il a fallu moins
d'un mois pour que commence à sortir des
histoires de créativité extraordinaire
des élèves face à chatpt grâce à
des enseignants qui avaient la liberté
de d'inventer des cours qui utilisaient
chatpt à des fins de créativité et de
collaboration parce que lorsqu'un enfant
collabore avec la technologie lorsqu'un
élave est partenaire avec la technologie
il y a pas de limite à ce qu'il peut
faire c c'est très bien tout à l'heure
je parlais des des
conditions
de de de succès des systèmes éducatifs
quelque chose d'autre qu'on voit dans
les évaluations internationales c'est
que dans les systèmes qui réussissent
bien souvent il y a y a c'est important
qu'il ait une marge pour les enseignants
qu' soi pas trop dirigés et qu' puissent
utiliser cette marge pour se faire leur
propre corpus leurs propres exercices et
ainsi de suite et c'est là que sont
arrivés les meilleurs exemples l'exemple
que je viens de donner carte postale
j'aurais jamais pensé bon et c'est
normal quand tu as le nombre
de potentiels utilisateurs qui est
quelqu'un qui a une bonne idée quelque
part la puissance du la puissance du
nombre l' l'éducation nationale
traditionnellement est fort mauvaise
pour les expérimentations elle demande
des des formulaires a priori et tout ça
et c'est important
d'avoir espace d'autonomie de prise de
décision pour pour l'enseignant on
reviendra sur le côté enseignement et
intelligence artificielle un peu plus
tard dans notre émission je je voudrais
qu'on on aborde le côté intelligence
artificielle stabilité des marchés
lecture des marchés et tout ce qui va
avec spéculation financière en terme
prédictif est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous avez lu vu entendu 1000 doigts
dedans est-ce que ça vous fait peur
c'est bien en terme de guerre économique
ça va nous aider ça va pas nous aider
est-ce que ça va nous mettre une
laisse on verra euh le
secteur
financier depuis longtemps n'a guerre de
surmoi guerre de limite pour
expérimenter les algorithmes les plus
incroyables possibles l'un des parmi les
livres les plus marquant que j'ai jamais
vu sur les questions technologiques sont
les ouvrages Alexandre lomonier sur la
finance algorithmique trading haute
fréquence comme on dit parfois hyper
frequency trad hyper frequency trading
absolument les ouvrages de mon avec des
titres des titres étranges le premier
s'appelle 6 le deuxème s'appelle 5 le
3ème s'appelle 4 bon je crois qu'il y en
a fait que que trois sur ce thème et et
on voit ce cette espèce de monde des tas
d'algorithmes incompréhensibles qui
s'affrontent à l'échelle de la
milliseconde ou même de la microseconde
les milliards qui apparaissent qui
disparaissent cet
événement qui était un cas d'école en
2010 quelque part le flash crack de de
de mai 2010 où euh d'un coup là en
quelques minutes genre combien quelque
chose comme 1000 milliards ont disparu
puis sont réapparu peu à peu un truc de
fou et et et et là-dessus Jim Simons l'
des très très grand nom et un bon
mathématicien un très grand nom de la
finances algorithmique avec son son fond
Renaissance une vedette qui passe à la
télévision et qui dit le système est
stable c'est bien la preuve tout marche
bien quand on voit les milliards qui
disparaissent à foison comme ça et puis
qui réapparaissent je trouve pas ça
spécialement rassurant en terme de
stabilité bon et et et quand on voit
aussi le la la j'ai des j'ai des
collègues je me souviens de comment il
s'appelait mon collègue ramaacte
mathématicien qui est qui lui bosse à
l'Université Paris à un il faisait
partie des gens qui essayaient de
comprendre vraiment ce qui s'était passé
pendant le le flash crack et et de de
modéliser ça mathématiquement comprendre
quelles sont les lois est-ce qu'on
aurait pu prédire ce qui s'est passé et
cetera pas facile pas facile grande
opacité qu' y a là-dedans alors
maintenant ça ça se faisait avant que ce
soit la la grande époque de
l'intelligence artificielle maintenant
comme je voudrais insister là-dessus djà
il y a pas de bonne définition de
l'intelligence artificielle et tout
algorithme un temp un peu sophistiqué on
peut l'appeler intelligence artificielle
ce qui est dommage enfin c'est dommage
de d'utiliser le nom intelligence
artificiel pour tout ce qui est en fait
machine learning c'est ça de toute façon
comme c'est pas de l'intelligence on est
on a un truc qui est oui qui R de
confusion tout ça bon ou et et et en
tout cas euh euh le et en tout cas on a
là un un domaine dans lequel les
algorithmes s'en sont donnés à cœur joie
depuis des décennies depuis longtemps
bien plus longtemps que l'époque il a de
nos jours ouais oui oui tout à fait et
euh j'ai été directrice d'un département
d'interaction humain machine et
euh les banques les grandes banques les
grands groupes financiers venez vers moi
pour me demander nos meilleurs étudiants
pour créer des systèmes
compréhensible des banquiers qui
utilisaient les algorithmes et ça ça
m'intéressait parce
que les banquiers les jeunes qui
travaillent en finances ne savent pas
forcément ce qu'ils font ça aussi c'est
intéressant et donc on avait besoin
d'expert en interaction humain machine
pour leur créer
des des comment dire ce qu'on appelle ça
en français euh en anglais je vais trad
ouais non plus je trouve pas qu'on je
trouve pas en français ça me bloque
l'anglais aussi malheureusement les oui
des interfaces des espacces d'interfac
qui permettent aux gens de savoir ce
qu'ils font parce que haute fréquence
c'est vraiment haute fréquence et ça
peut disparaître heureux apparaître sans
qu' qu'il puisse refaire ce qu'il vient
de
faire ils t'ont proposé de l'argent pour
ça alors j'étais dans un bus à la plus
grande conférence d'interaction humain
machine ça s'appelle kille et j'étais
dans le bus qui nous amena de
l'hôtel au centre de congrès et une
femme s'est penchée vers moi et elle a
dit vous voulez quoi pour vos meilleurs
étudiants tout ce que je veux c'est une
semaine
d'avance bon je j'ai pas accepté mais
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant et
aujourd'hui sa carte non pourquoi tu
veux investir dans sa boîte non je veux
pas investir dans sa boîte je veux
savoir pour qui réellement elle
travaille ah ouais je rappelle plus
quelle Mary Lynch
peut-être mais aujourd'hui je vois que
les grandes banques les grand groupes
financiers ont de grands groupes
d'experts en apprentissage automatique
et qui font des avances que personne
d'autre ne fait des avances que qui
avancent les finances mais qui avancent
plein d'autres choses aussi
euh je vois des gens qui quittent
l'Académie qui quittent la fac pour
aller aller travailler dans des boîtes
pour gérer d'énormes groupes de
chercheurs en en machine learning en
apprentissage automatique et au niveau
technique là où il y a pas si longtemps
les formations les plus côté célèbre en
en mathématique financière était basé
sur du calcul stochastique des formules
de Black SHS des des questions de
probabilité qui remontent des des
notions de martingal des des des
questions qui remontent même à à bless
Pascal en tout cas basé sur des modèles
probabilistes les derniers et des
modèles probabilistes expliqu en quelque
sorte il y a une décennie ou quelque
chose comme ça 10 ou 15 ans ça a été
remplacé dans dans bien des cas par
des formation et des des techniques
basées beaucoup plus sur l'apprentissage
on se fiche savoir quel modèle
sous-jacent mais tout est basé sur
Analyse de analyse de ce qui veut dire
boîte noire par définition no de ce qui
est fascinant c'est de voir que il y a
très peu de temps genre il y a quelques
jours ou une ou deux semaines deep mind
on sait que sur le plan de la
météorologie ils avaient des calculs qui
est de d'événements rares qui étaient
plus précis plus fiabl que ceux qui sont
développés par les les grands codes de
calcul météorologique explique deep mind
pourquoi c'est alors deep mind c'est le
la boîte fondée par demis hassabis
grande belle boîte d'intelligence
artificielle qui est devenue
mondialement célèbre avec alphago et son
pro son algorithme qui a battu à plat de
couture les meilleurs joueurs de de
godle l' époque deep mind a été est venu
maintenant dans le giron de Google
petite parenthèse deep mind était
britannique au départ de temps en temps
je me dis s'il y avait plus de cohésion
politique en Europe et si si si et la
Grande-Bretagne ben si ça se trouve elle
battrait pavillon européen maintenant la
face géopolitique de l'ya on serait
complètement changé bon et en tout cas
le le le Deep mind aujourd'hui c'est le
bras armé de Google c'est eux qui
viennent de sortir Jini Jemini comme tu
veux comme tu veux l'appeler
lia qui a affiché des résultats très
impressionnants tout récemment pour
concurrencer chat GPT c'est eux avant
qui avait annoncé des résultats très
forts sur la prédiction des formes d'une
protéine à partir de son à partir de sa
de sa structure et un certain nombre de
réalisations impressionnant comme ça di
a appliqué à différents sujets
et deep mind donc a quelques jours
montre qu'un sujet qui semblait un vrai
sujet d'équations avec des modèles
sous-jacents des équations de mécanique
des flit comme utilisent les gens du JEC
avec des équations de Navier stock des
équations qui parlent de de température
de pression de vitesse du fluide et un
système déterministe qu'on simule eux en
boîte noir en le faisant en
apprentissage automatique ils arrivaient
à faire des prédictions à l'échelle de
10 jours par exemple de quand
connaissant l'état du monde
météorologique à un moment donné
qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans 10 jours
et à prèdire des événements singuliers
avec une précision c'est paru dans dans
Science nature il a très peu de temps
donc qui était supérieur à ce que
donnent les modèles établis mondialement
en matière de de météo c'est quelque
chose qui va
s'avarer un grand défi par rapport au à
la question de la
prédiction intéressant ah ouais je vous
ai pas fait venir pour bouserad quand
même alors quo que c'est très
intéressant de pouser un C on apprend
plein de trucs dans les supermarchés
surtout comment il te trace comment il
te repère ensuite comment il t'envoie de
la pub par exemple si tu restes
longtemps devant un rayon quel type de
pub tu vas avoir si ça a déclenché un
geste d'achat pas de geste d'achat si tu
mets ta main dans le rayon pas ta main
dans le rayon c'est bon tu veux dire la
caméra analyse
oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça quand
on on voit notre population monitorer et
et qu'on voit l'information retraité
pour vendre provoquer des actes d'achat
chat est-ce qu'on pourrait pas provoquer
des actes
éducatifs d'amour
d'empathie est-ce que on peut avoir des
scientifiques qui expliquent que la
logique marchande ça va un
temps je pense qu'il y a deux choses
mélangées dans ce que tu viens de dire
l'une c'est
comment vendre en regardant les actes
des personnes et en les observant et
peut-être en les formant en les poussant
d'un côté à l'autre et l'autre c'est ce
qu'on appelle le noge c'est-à-dire
Macron il aime beaucoup ça oui ah oui
c'est son kiff ah d'accord ok le covid
cétait extraordinaire il a reçu des bons
conseils de certains cabinet de conseil
qui finit
en et il je beaucoup je te laisse
expliquer à notre communauté ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le nudging alors le
nudging le nudge c'est un terme je pense
que ça a été utilisé pour la première
fois euh par un chercheur britannique
euh qui a découvert que en disant euh
bonjour euh
90 % de vos voisins ont envoyé leurs
impôts est-ce que vous allez envoyer le
vôtre donc c'était le premier ou un des
premiers exemples et ça a marchait
ou
euh ce que ça vous intéresse de savoir
que avec peu d'argent vous pouvez
atteindre le même niveau de vie que les
personnes avec qui vous travaillez enfin
bon c'est des c'est nudger c'est pousser
les gens vers de bonnes actes en leur
comparant à leur père enfin c'est ça la
la définition technique je pense si je
me trompe pas
et
ça avait été inventé pour aider le
gouvernement à changer les habitudes ça
a été utilisé avec beaucoup de succès
pour aider les gens à arrêter de fumer
par exemple très très réussi mais
évidemment ça soulève des craintes que
ça peut nous faire faire des choses
qu'on n pas envie de
faire comme quoi bah comme acheter un
million d'euros de
patate douce lorsque on gagne pas 1
million d'euros dans sa vie ou acheter
une voiture très chère à crédit voilà ça
ouais ouais mais et tu tu sais comment
on peut détourner ça c'est très très
vieux le le le noging ou tu connais la
blague comment tu fais dire rouge et
marteau à quelqu'un tu fais three times
se 21 three times se tu lui fais répéter
répéter répéter donc tu lui actives son
mode défensif et tu dis donne-moi
donne-moi un outil et le premier truc
qui te répète c'est un marteau parce
qu'il veut te taper dessus il suis dit
donne-moi une couleur et la première
chose qu'il voit c'est du rouge d'accord
ok tu connaissais pas cette blague jeis
sû tu la connais toi ouais moi je conis
j'avais qu'est-ce qu'on va dire euh
dans à un moment j'avais pas mal potassé
les bouquins des des gens des B
cognitifs je dire dan canman Olivier
Siboni cassenstein et quelques autres
qui ont travaillé sur toutes ces exper
j'en avais vu une qui m'avait fait
halluciner qui appelit qu'il appelaient
l'effet Floride Florida effect tu
puisquon parla de la Floride tout à
l'heure peut-être ça sera uneide associé
dans dans l'imaginaire américain à
quelque chose d'âgé l'endroit où on va
prendre sa retraite bon ouais et alors
pas du tout moi ça je pense à la
bouffe mais tu penses à la bouffe quoi
qu'on dise si je Christian jusqu'à la
flor toujours bon en tout cas dans cette
expérience on on prend deux groupes
de groupes de de de personnes de
volontaires et on les fait travailler
sur une activité avec des mots à
manipuler et l'un des groupes manipule
des des mots qui sont un peu tous les
registres l'autre groupe manipule des
mots qui sont tous dans le registre de
de de de la vieillesse alors par exemple
on parle de Floride de Cannes de maison
de qui sait quoi plein de mots qui
évoque indirectement le le le trè
âgeite il essaie de nous déconcentrer de
nous énerver là mais on tombe pas dans
son piège on reste serin non mais toi tu
as l'habitude donc
ça et donc non mais je t'ai fait un von
close VZ la dernière fois tu l'as pas vu
venir ah ouais je m'en souviens encore
de ton de ton de ton F close Vitz c'est
le moment de temp en voyer une grosse
charge en plein en plein concentré sur
toi et alors en tout cas après une fois
que tu as les deux groupes tu leur dis
on va aller maintenant faire une autre
expérience et on va passer en autre
salle pour ça ils ne le savent pas mais
en fait on s'en fout de l'expérience
qu'on va le donner après ce qui compte
c'est le temps qu'ils vont mettre à
traverser le couloir et on voit que le
groupe qui a travaillé sur les mots
Floride et tout est significativement
plus lent à traverser le couloir que que
que le premier groupe il est influencé
dans sa démarche il va d'un ton plus
lent un ton pas de sénateur vers le vers
la vers l'autre pièce moi j'appelleraai
là ça plutôt stéréotype TR non c'est pas
la menace de du stéréotype euh la menace
du enfin je pense que ça s'appelle comme
ça en français stéréotype threat c'est
le fait que lors que on a de groupes euh
deux groupes de de filles qui travaille
sur euh des problèmes en math et à l'un
des groupes on dit ne t'inquiète pas
malgré le fait que tu es fille tu vas
pouvoir faire ça et à l'autre groupe on
dit simplement euh voilà des questions
en math et
moi pour moi les deux phénomènes sont
différents parce que là là tu leur dis
là tu leur dis ce qu'ils vont faire t
dans l'autre tu leur dis pas tu leur
fais manipuler des mots sans leur dire
de quoi il s'agit et quel est le
intéressant Justus tu le tu leur dis
alors tu Brit directement oui alors
merci et et et et je vais je vais
enrichir encore il une autre variante du
problème que dit Justine qui est encore
plus intéressante qui est qui est bien
connue en sur les questions éducation
mathématique un certains problèmes il il
y a certains problèmes de de géométrie
assez visuel
dans une classe tu leur dis voilà on va
faire un problème de mathématique en
avant dans l'autre classe tu leur dis on
va faire un problème artistique le même
problème et tu vas voir que dans la
classe on leur dit c'est artistique les
filles vont mieux réussir que dans la
classe où on dit c'est un problème
mathématique si en plus et là on se
rapproche encore ce que dit Justine le
prof a pris soin de rappeler c'est
dommage les filles sont moins doué que
les que que que les garçons en mat on sa
ça connerie c'est une grosse connerie
mais si tu le si tu dis ça ben ça va
être autoréalisateur ça change c'est
Claude steel un psychologue qui a
découvert cet effet et qui a démontré
des des centaines de vériations par
exemple si on a un groupe de
filles asiatique souche asiatique et on
leur
dit
d'origine ne vous inquiétez pas vous
êtes filles mais vous allez réussir à se
problème de math elles réussissent moins
bien si on leur dit vous êtes asiatique
vous allez trouver ces problèmes faciles
elles apprennent plus al quand je vous
entends parler tu as fini Justine ou pas
oui vas-y quand je vous entends parler
de mon petit siège j'ai l'impression que
vous m'expliquiez la guerre cognitive
pour les nuls alors je trouve ça très
sympa parce que bon je suis sûr que dans
notre tu non mais t'inquiète j'arrive
donc donc je trouve ça très sympa parce
que vous êtes très très pédagogue et
très pédagogique avec la partie de notre
communauté infime qui ne connaî pas ce
type de sujet on va essayer de monter un
peu le
niveau ah on est à bas niveau bon
d'accord et donc je suis désolé de vous
le dire mais quand je vous entends
parler sur des questions de propagande
sur les questions de ce qui est
maintenant appelé sa guerre
cognitive je voudrais qu'on qu'on REP
parce que c'est une forme de guerre
cognitive que vous inconscient ça dépend
si Guer touours négative ou
pas pas mal h quand un prof brime
bride une 50 % de sa classe féminine en
disant bon comprenez les filles c'est un
peu toujours teb en math donc on va vous
donner un tiersts tout de suite c'est un
hack c'est un hack de leur tête
peut-être inconscient à cause du du de
la misenderie de de de de du prof ou de
son
passif élargissons ça à l'échelle
étatique à l'échelle quoi étatique
étatique d'accord en terme par exemple
on voit le TikTok des Chinois beaucoup
plus intellectuel avec des choses pour
mieux fonctionner des cours d'histoire
des cours de math et nous notre TikTok
c'est la le de l'humanité non je dirais
pas ça c'est c'est plus
abrutissant
chronophage très je dirais c'est ça
active des zones du cerveau qui doivent
être je pense sensiblement les mêmes que
les aires du cerveau sensi à la
cocaïne donc en terme de guerre
cognitive cette nouvelle forme de
propagande sous stéroïde grâce au réseau
sociaux grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle quand on détourne ça
qu'est-ce que ça ça peut générer à
l'échelle nationale sur une population
ça peut la
démoraliser ça peut l'empêcher de
résoudre des problèmes ça peut
l'empêcher de se concentrer sur son
futur son approche des relations je vous
je suis pas d'accord avec la prémisse
alors reformule-moi la prémisse c'est
que en Chine TikTok est intellectuel et
chez nous TikTok te rend bête j'ai pas
dit rend bête te rend dépendant bah tu
tu as quand même dit plutôt bête enfin
tu as pas utilisé ce mot mais utilisé
quel mot euh tu as dit
euh tu'impliques dans des trucs pas
intéressants chronophage voilà et ça
c'est pas forcément de dépendance
c'est c'est des choses enfin je pense
est-ce que l'intellect peut être
chronophage est-ce que les cours de math
peuvent être chronophages je pense que
si ça dépend si tu aimes ou pas voilà
exactement donc je pense que la
comparaison que tu fais entre TikTok en
deux pays c'est pas ça que tu voulais
dire j'aime fumer c'est pas bon pour moi
mais la nicotine active des des centes
de mon cerveau qui me rendre
dépendant on n'est pas convaincu enfin
pas toutes les études montrent que
TikTok et autres active les centres du
cerveau qui nous amène du plaisir enfin
plus qu'utre plus que le chocolat par
exemple je suis je suis pas convaincu
que qu'on peut prendre tout ça comme
donné pour se demander où ça nous mène
je suis enfin tu tu es peut-être plus il
y a une pour moi une dépendance qui se
fait au chot d'information quelle que
soit la la la le type que ça prend le
type d'information mais ça c'est quelque
chose et en plus quand on est dans
certaines situations exposé politique on
le ressent on le ressent durement
euh je voudrais insister sur le fait que
ces manipulations de certaines
idéologies par des algorithmes elles
sont déjà à l'œuvre bien sûr dans
certains cas ce sont des gouvernements
qui les font exemple la propagande russe
antifançaise en Afrique ou ailleurs elle
se fait à tous les niveaux y compris sur
les réseaux et elle se fait très bien
hélas parmi d'autres parmi d'autres
parmi plein d'autres actions oui parmi
d'autres propagandes exactement a ple
propagande mais tu as aussi par exemple
la propagande des lobistes pour les
énergies fossiles à travers le monde où
les propagandes de tous les intérêts qui
sont contre je te rassure il y a des
lobbyistes aussi dans les énergies
renouvelables ouais mais pour l'instant
il y a une différence de puissance qui
est très fortement à l'avantage des
énergies fossiles très fortement bon et
eux aussi savent très bien ils ont des
bons algorithmiciens et tu a un un
énorme des budgets qui chifent pour tous
les pour tout ça en milliards à travers
le monde et par exemple une tendance
très claire sur les réseaux à la montée
du climatodénialisme ou
climatoscepticisme comme tu veux qui est
quantifié mesuré notre collègue David
chavalarias de l'Institut des systèmes
complexes qui a écrit l'excellent
bouquin toxique data pour analyser la
façon dont les algorithmes participent
au renforcement des convictions à la
polarisation des des opinions sur les
débats et ainsi de suite à montrer
comment l'action algorithmique avec des
intérêts des lobby identifiables
agissant très systématiquement sur le
Web est en train de gagner sur certaines
de ces secteurs et un autre livre que je
suis sûr que tu aimes autant que que moi
c'est weapons of math destruction qui
qui démontre la même chose c'est un
livre formidable weapons of math
ouais c'est même j'aime tellement que
c'est moi qui fait la préface de la
version française oui ça m'étonne pas
oui ou ouais revenons à et en français
pardon pardon et en français c'est
algorithme la bombe à retardement le
titre qui a été choisi parce que le jeu
de mots sur masse et et mathématique
était intradisible
ou en terme de propagande étatique et de
guerre cognitive sur nos propres
populations sur la population europé
comment on fait pour rendre notre
population plus résiliente plus
endurcie face à des intelligences
artificielles pilotées par des états
béliqueux qui mettrait à mal notre
population je vais donner un exemple de
l'histoire dans les années
60 une mère de famille a remarqué que
après avoir regardé la télévision ses
enfants reclamaient toujours des céréal
sucré la pube euh oui alors regardez ce
qui regardé et elle s'est rendu compte
que les seuls pubs pendant les périodes
où les enfants regardaient la télé après
l'école c'était des pubs pour des
nourritures sucrées mal pour mauvaise
pour leur santé
addictif et qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait
elle est allé devant le gouvernement
américain plusieurs fois elle a fait des
miracles et elle a réussi que le
gouvernement attribue une part de son
budget vers la télévision publique et
c'est ça qui est né la télévision
publique pour enfants aux
États-Unis donc encore une fois
l'histoire nous apprend que rien de tout
ça est nouveau
que rendre addicte notre population et
et ben c'est un vieux jeu et on a des
moyens de gagner encore une fois avec
l'éducation l'histoire est jolie oui
mais oui premièrement elle aurait été
encore plus belle si le gouvernement
avait choisi d'interdire les publicités
pour les aliments sucrés pendant le
temps d'émission des enfants je pense
qu'il je pense qu'il en fait et ensuite
la courbe de poids de nos amis
américains s pas statistiquement
vraiment arrangé depuis je te rassure la
population française c'est pareil oui
alors je que jeis te dire la rue de
sésam ça s'appelle comme ça en français
non la rue sésam sésam l'émission de
télévision oui oui oui mais c'est cette
émission avec Casimir euh oui voilà
exactement oui pourquoi tu nous parles
de ça parce que John Gans Coy donc la
femme qui est allée devant le
gouvernement américain c'est elle qui a
lancé cette cette émission et cette
émission a été inventée pour donner un
alternatif aux émiss
aussi sucré que leur pub
c'est bon ça c alors César Street SESAM
Street sésam sésam sésam s comm comme
les graines de
sésam j'insiste sur la question
américaine moi ça m marqué j'ai j'ai été
ça m'est arrivé à trois reprises d'être
prof invité pour un semestre aux
États-Unis et ça m'est arrivé d'y être
avec des des jeunes enfants elle a qu
quelle université j'ai enseigné à à
George à Atlanta c'était la première
fois que je partais à l'étranger et
c'était c'était important pour moi
j'avais un cours de un cours de Master
et Atlanta comme premier endroit où on
arrive c'est quelque chose c'est quelque
chose une qui est en train de monter
beaucoup sur les plans sur les questions
culturelles et Cera très bonne et avec
une bonne articulation entre théorique
et application très intéressant ou je
précise tout de suite que malgré tout ce
que j'ai pu dire contre les États-Unis
le gouvernement américain par rapport à
Jan Assange les États-Unis ont joue un
rôle majeur dans ma carrière
scientifique il y a eu Atlanta qui a été
très important dans ma carrière des bons
contacts des bonnes personnes un bouquin
qui est sorti de là qui a été important
pour la suite puis ça a été à Berkley
puis ça a été à Princeton à chaque fois
6 mois tous les 5 ans en gros et à
chaque fois ça a été des des événements
majeurs j'aurais jamais pas de médaille
fil sans ses sans ces séjours dans
l'université américaine je peux ça me
rend d'autant plus à l'aise pour
critiquer les États-Unis qu' a une part
de de d'Amérique dans mes veines voilà
tout à fait attends fini ton histoire
alors et alors oui je fini donc donc et
donc euh ça nous avait complètement
bluffé ma femme et moi quand on se rend
compte à un moment tu sais ALIR le le le
pédiatre avec notre petit gamin et tout
ça qui a qui est né en France et tout ça
qui est ÉtatsUnis et qu'on voit que les
courbes de poids tu sais et les courbes
de poids ben c'est pas les mêmes aux
États-Unis en France la courbe de poids
du du gamin de de de 0 à à 3 ans ou je
sais pas quoi ma ma petite elle devait
avoir 1 an à l'époque puisqu'elle a à
peu près elle a fait ses premiers pas
aux États-Unis et ça nous a juste juste
bluffé de voir que dès la naissance le
poids attendu du petit bébé américain
c'est pas le même que le poids attendu
du petit bébé français je veux dire il y
a un système qui est structurellement
sucré du du début à la fin ouais ouais
ouais tout à fait ben on sait que le
lait qu'on vend en Afrique aussi bien
qu'en France aujourd'hui et aux
États-Unis même le lait à un certain
moment était sucré enfin
c'est pas
étonnant question internet qui va
rebondir sur nos petites histoires les
questions voir les législations sur les
intelligences artificielles sont-elles
réellement sous-estimé ou sousfinancé
dans l'Union européenne et en
France pard les question sur les
législation ouais est-ce qu'on les
encadre on parlait d'encadrer les pubs à
la télé pour éviter le hacking le hack
sur les cerveaux des gamin pour réclamer
de la
bouffe est-ce que nous on a à l'échelle
européenne à l'échelle du pays à
l'échelle mondiale une réglementation
qui dit bon il y a des trucs qu'il faut
pas faire genre on évite de développer
une intelligence artificielle qui
pourrait avoir tel type d'impact où on
évite de faire travailler une
intelligence artificielle sur la
création de virus informatique ou de
virus tout court ou d'armes biologique
ou de choses comme ça excuse-moi mais
bon plus for aux étatsun il y a plus ce
qui se fait ici qu'aux États-Unis tu
veux dire dans les labos qui se trouvent
sur ceci non je veux dire rgpd ah bien
sûr alors premièrementa premièrement
sans contestation l'Europe est de loin
le continent le plus régulé en matière
d'IA c'est le rgpd c'est le le EDSA le
DMA le a Act peut-être d'autres et les
acronymes de tout ça ça veut dire
quoi je sais plus rgpd c'est le
règlement général de protection des
données jdpier en anglais le le dsadm
c'est plus que ça veut dire digital
service Act quelque chose comme ça bon
et et et
maintenant un dans un sujet le sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle premièrement
il y a pas de définition claire de ce
que c'est qu'a deuxièmement c'est un
sujet qui est très pragmatique et
expérimental il est normal que la
législation la réglementation soit
pragmatique aussi c'estàd qu'il faudrait
accepter dans certains cas de revenir en
arrière pour donner juste un exemple que
j'ai vu durement quand je travaillais
sur le rapport il a et que je revois
depuis le secteur données de S est un
secteur surrégulé je veux dire par là
que la régulation est tellement forte
que les les
expériences de quoi voilà les
expériences est-ce que est-ce que avec
Deia on peut sélectionner un embryon non
c'est pas ça la santé en général est
surréguli en France parce qu'il a eu le
scandale du sang contaminé parce qu'il y
a eu avant le fichage ethnique dans les
dans les années 40 et c'est resté dans
les mémoires et dans les réglementations
parce que la médecine est payée par le
gouvernement ce qui permet beaucoup plus
de régulation que aux États-Unis où on
le paye soi-même donc c'est difficile à
réguler mais les les médecins ils sont
aujourd'hui très critiques ils disent
que c'est devenu impossible de monter
les expériences en France parce que
administrativement tu t'en sors pas la
quantité de contrôle est considérable et
ils externalisent leurs expériences tu
sais que si tu veux aujourd'hui euh un
pe que les comme les gains de fonction
avec le covid ah bah ça avait fait tout
un tout évidemment le le le le le les
les cathédrales comme j'ai entendu une
experte en droit en en droit de la la
santé dire la cathédrale administrative
que représente la mise en place d'un
d'un bon essai en France et est
décourageante dans bien des cas moi
j'essaie de lancer une étude dans des
écoles je sais pas si je vais arriver
parce que le la régulation veut que je
vais jamais me voir face à face à des
enfants avec des études que je pense
être positive pour leur santé et la
santé de leurs enfants parce que il y a
une telle régulation médecine éducation
il a mais moi je m'inspire beaucoup de
ce qu' dit un de mes collègues à carnig
mon Tom Mitchell alors Tom Mitchell a
écrit le livre qui s'appelle machine
learning le livre il a fondé le premier
département de machine learning dans le
monde c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
dessus depuis 40 ans et lui il fait
remarquer que ça n'a pas de sens de
réguler lia complètement je suis
complètement d'accord ça veut rien dire
si on veut réguler il faut réguler les
utilisations totalement d'accord voilà
et par exemple ou non mais totalement
d'accord par
exemple interdire la pub pour les SUV
revendication de longue date des
écologistes interdire la pub pour tout
ce qui a une forte empreinte carbone et
cetera quel que soit le mode de pub que
ça soit fait avec de l'a ou au doigt
mouillés ou avec n'importe quelle
technique et tout ça ça c'est la
finalité que tu dois que tu dois juguler
et et réguler et donc est-ce qu'il y a
une une régulation de l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle sur la
production de virus à caractère
militaire est-ce qu'il y a une
régulation sur l'intelligence
artificielle
Infiné le résultat serait de développer
une arme avec une technologie crispe
pour aller cibler X ou Y
corpsque la phrase que tu viens de dire
c'était quelque chose du genre est-ce
que il y a une régulation pour une
technologie qui aurait comme fin de et
ben c'est loin de la technologie
elle-même c'est loin de l'utilisation
donc encore une fois utilisation mais au
niveau de l'utilisation et non pas de ce
qui pourrait être
utilisé sais il y a des gens qui disent
des experts en en apprentissage
automatique en machine learning qui
jouent la provoque en en disant dès
qu'on écrit une moyenne on peut appeler
ça l'intelligence artificielle tellement
la définition est flou bah oui la
probabilité c'est la frantisage
automatique alors je voudrais maintenant
rebondir sur un autre truc qu'a dit qu'a
dit Justine paraît de Carn guiméon qui
est un exemple étudié et célèbre de
d'établissement dans lequel une action
féministe a eu lieu avec succès sur la
sur les questions de des femmes dans la
tech ouais c'est vrai ouais ouais ouais
c'est formidable et il y a il y a
l'exemple de Caron il y a un autre
exemple en Norvège NTNU je crois qu'
s'appelle quelque chose comme ça dans
lesquels avec une action résolue et le
principal obstacle c'est de vouloir le
faire le pourcentage de de femmes
travaillant des postes clés en
algorithmique dans enfin formé dans ces
écoles et passé de genre 15 % à genre 40
%. aujourd'hui les femmes sont très sous
représenté dans l'algorithmique et de
moins en moins il y a plus il y avait
plus de proportionnellement plus de
femmes programmeuses en France dans les
années 80 qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'on est
dans des époques de clichés qui
augmentent et l'époque du numérique
augmente aussi les clichés globalement
avec ça on narrive pas trop à savoir
parce que chaque fois qu'on essaie
quelque chose ça marche pas et donc on a
beau euh se dire que c'est à cause des
clichés c'est certainement en parti à
cause des clichés euh non mais il y y a
tu sais a quand on quand on bossait sur
le rapport d'abord c'est l'un des sujets
sur lequel rien n'a été fait en France
depuis l'époque du céit l'une des
recommandations majeures dans dans le
rapport que j'ai rendu en 2018 il ne
s'est rien passé dessus depuis et et je
suis dans un certain nombre de projets
je conseille le projet de ha de tuin qui
s'appelle systémique qui vise très
précisément à faire du buzz et du rafu
autour de cette question avec des
coloques et cetera et à l'époque tu dis
la propagande pour dire les femmes c'est
très important pour plein de raisons
pour des questions de d'ambiance de
travail pour des questions d'éviter les
billets pour des questions de d'image de
de du rôle travail ambiance de travail
aussi bien sûr une un une ambiance de
les équipes qui sont de façon très
prépondérante masculine c'est pas le
même genre BR la culture Bro la culture
Bro comme comment on l'appelle ouais
voilà h comment c'était brotopia avait
ce ce ce livre qui était qui était sorti
à une époque pour parler de comment
c'éit la culture matchiste dans dans le
monde de la tech de la silicone Vallé
tout ça et ça c'est sont des choses qui
à la fin sont sont délétaires avec aussi
des répercussions mauvaises sur la sur
la productivité ou
des mais mais mais aussi du mal-être
alors tu me lances vas-y continue et et
et alors pour pour terminer ce donc dans
C dans ce domaines là en 2018 on avait
citer dans le rapport une expérience un
exemple qui avait fait grand bruit quand
c'est sorti être en 2017 ê quelque chose
comme ça on avait constaté quand on
tapait CEO PDG dans la partart de
recherche de Google on regardait ce qui
sortait dans Google Image on voyait que
genre les 95 premiers qui sortaient
étaient des hommes bon
96e était une femme sauf que c'était la
poupée Barbie PDG bon et P Barbie PDG
ben tu as une Barbie tu as des Barbies
oui ils ont sorti une Barbie ingénieur
ils ont sorti une Barbie PDG et c'est
des barbiiees identiques à toutes les
Barbies sauf que PDG a un une
servi oui un attach case et Barbie
ingénieur porte tes
lunettes et alors tu vois ici la p Barb
le B le B Barbie et la puissance de la
réverbération à l'époque il y avait déjà
genre enfin un tiers des PDG en Amérique
étaient des femmes ou quelque chose
comme ça en tout cas ce que renvoyit le
numérique comme typique était très très
très favorisé par rapport à la réalité
de terrain donc tu me lances sur les
biaets de programmation les Biss
d'apprentissage programmation bet de
représentation bet d'apprentissage aussi
que toutes les études ont démontré que
plus de diversité on a dans une équipe
le plus fort les idées qui sortent donc
ok bon il veut pas en
parler parler ça fait 20 20 minutes qu'
on parle donc là j'aimerais qu'on aborde
le côté technique quand il y a que des
browsers qui entraînent des des
intelligences artificielles des brosurs
avec une culture de de poilu de Toufu
genre on fait la guerre on joue à la
bataille navale il y a Barbie ingénieur
qui sort 25 ans après mais nous on a
notre culture de on entraî notre
intelligence artificielle comme des
brosur bon l'intelligence artificielle
qui va faire la guerre comme des browers
alors on dit pas Brother on dit Bro
juste pour ton avenir d'accord faut faut
le l comme prierord en
préliminaire faut rappeler c'est très
clair que
la
la c'est un fait d'expérience que le le
le le poids des la responsabilité sur
les guerres les impacts environnementaux
les inégalités tout ce que tu veux et
bien plus du côté masculin que du côté
féminin l'impact écologique
environnemental des hommes est
considérablement pire que celui des
femmes échelle mal voilà alors
ensuite pour préparer la discussion sur
les bis je vais dire quelques mots sur
l'apprentissage automatique on tourne
depuis on en parle tout depuis tout à
l'heure parce que il y a on sait pas
bien définir mais apprentissage on sait
ce que c'est apprentissage c'est l'une
des techniques qui permet un
algorithme de de s'entraîner à répondre
à une question qui lui est posée il y a
trois grands types de stratégies
d'apprentissage le premier qui est
historiquement le premier qui est le
plus simple à comprendre c'est comme
l'apprentissage d'un parent à un G ou
d'un d'un d'un prof de fac à ses
étudiants il donne des règles il donne
des règles on les reproduit dans
l'algorithme tac je fais C je fais ça je
fais ça on appelit ça une époque des
systèmes expert mais c'est exactement ce
que ça fait quelle règle pour donner
quel résultat symbolique il y a
symbolique il y a
ontologique deème type d'apprentissage
par l'exemple on apprend à parler à nos
gamins pas en leur donnant les règles de
grammaire mais en parlant ils
reproduisent les phrases et c'estes
erreurs on les rige quand il faut on
supervise comme ça en dis ouais là tu
t'es trompé si ça et plus ils apprennent
d'exemples plus plus il les refont et il
les modifie extrapole et ainsi de suite
ça ça s'appuie sur des bases de données
d'apprentissage c'est des bases
d'exemples trème type d'apprentissage
par exploration par renforcement donc
deuxème type qui donne lieu à
reinforcement learning par exemple où on
donne des retours et le système apprend
parce que on lui dit ça c'est bon ça
c'est mauvais trè typ et et trème
type qui va être une exploration où on
va système lui-même calcule et dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe comme comme ça
avait été fait pour le jeu de Go je vais
essayer tel coup tel coup tel autre coup
et et et et j'explore comme ça même des
situations qui sont jamais dans mes
exemples aujourd'hui ce qui est le
dominant c'est la partie exemple dans la
plupart des intelligences artificielles
et la qualité de la réponse de l'al
rythme dépend beaucoup de la base
d'exemple qui lui a été fourni très bien
analysé dans l'ouvrage que citit Justine
tout à l'heure Cathy o'il weapons of
mass destruction par exemple on a pu
montrer que tel algorithme utilisé dans
certains états par les prisons
américaines dans les PR par les
administrations pénitentiaire américaine
pour déterminer si on va donner une
grosse peine ou grosse peine ou liberté
conditionnelle à à tel ou tel était
raciste pas parce que les programmeurs
étaient racistes mais parce qu' ça
s'appuyent sur un corpus de décision
antérieur qui étit systématiquement
biaisé et systématiquement
raciste et des ou d'autres exemples on
voit
que des certaines populations ça peut
être des femmes ou des des personnes
avec des noms qui indiquent que ce sont
des des des personnes immigrées de telle
ou telle partie du monde ont un moins
bon accès que les autres à un crédit ou
à tel ou tel emploi bon et et ici on
voit
le la la perversité que ça peut être
l'al RMIsation de ces tâches parce que
ça reproduit les B humains mais en plus
ça les ça les enquiste dans un programme
ça les encore plus dur à détecter
oui tout à
faitfin je peux continuer je peux donc
aujourd'hui la trè le trè type
d'apprentissage c'est ce qu'on appelle
transformer ou peut-être de façon plus
exacte self attention mechanism
c'estàdire quand lance la machine on lui
dit de trouver des patterns de trouver
les les les les patrons ou les schéma et
de décider ce qui est important et ce
qui n'est pas
important ça c'est ce qui a été enfin
bon c'est pas exactement le cas j'allais
dire c'est que c'est ça qui a été
utilisé pour chat GBT et c'est vrai sauf
que peu de gens le savent ça a commencé
avec les modèles transformer où on leur
a donné des billions euh non on dit pas
billions on dit milliards et des
milliards de documents et le système a
trouvé des schémas a construit des
schémas à travers ce qu'il a trouvé et
puis de là a pu euh inventer des phrases
qui n'ont jamais été vues sur les
schémas de ce que le système a vu mais
peu de gens savent que c'est pas que ça
que chatjbt a commencé avec ça et puis
il y a aussi une équipe en en Afrique
qui fait du reinforcement learning
c'est-à-dire qui prend ce qui est
construit par le système et qui dit ça
c'est bon ça c'est mauvais ça c'est
mauvais ça c'est mauvais ça c'est bon et
peu de gens savent à quel point des
personnes sont impliqués dans ces
décisions ce qui veut dire que ces
personnes qui ont des biais ça rentre
encore dans le transformer model dans le
self attention meéchanisme de de système
comme CHBT d' part si je peux continuer
parce que je pense que c'est très
important pour les gens qui savent pas
trop de quoi il il est question avec
chat GPT avec les autres systèmes qui
sont inventés bah depuis 6 mois enfin
c'est vraiment tout
neuf l'autre gros problème c'est que ces
systèmes ont été euh entraînés donc on
leur a donné à manger pour ainsi dire
des milliards et des milliards de
documents de partout de R
livran forchan exactement des chats et
cetera et ils ont commencé à parler mais
on continue à les former
et wikipéia est de plus en plus fait de
ce qui a été inventé par chat GPT
c'est-à-dire que ces systèmes commencent
à se former à leur propre output OK
pour empoisonner ça il faut faire
comment pourquoi pour empoisonner
l'apprentissage ah bah c'est
facile comprends pourquoi je pose cette
question bah oui enfin les documents on
dit garbage in garbage out poubelle vers
la l'entrée poubelle en sort enfin les
dégâts les enfin vous voyez ce que je
veux
dire donc ça c'est un problème et le
deuxème problème c'est que si ils
s'auto mangent enfin s'ils s'entraînent
sur leur propre sortie ça veut dire que
ça va être de pire en pire ça
s'empoisonne s'ils mangent leur propre
merde oui exactement oui et il y a pas
beaucoup de
protéines pour faire des gâteaux c'est
compliqué manque de nutriment oui voilà
est-ce que un état peut empoisonner ça
est-ce que un groupe extérieur un groupe
privé
un groupe piloté par un autre État peut
empoisonner ça est-ce que ça a déjà été
fait par exemple sur Wikipédia on sait
que il y a des groupes qui tu veux
rbondir CD non enfin sur Wikipédia tu as
une guerre de la de l'information qui
est tout temps là comme Wikipédia est
l'un
des très rares projets qui sont
restés dans l'idéal originel idéal de de
la création du du web il est normal que
ce soit la source de beaucoup de
convoitises et de beaucoup d'Atta tac
avec des ouis mais j'ai une solution
contre ça tu mets 50000 € avec une prime
sur qui fait quoi avec trois tueurs en
série russe t'inquié pas que ils vont
moins faire les malins les extrémistes
de gauche ou de droite hein non ce qui
est bien chez Wikipédia c'est que il y a
des guerres de
d'éditeurs mais euh est-ce que tu as les
fameux éditeurs est-ce que tu t'es amusé
à les mapper et ben bien sûr enfin les
les les Chaval aut ils font granding sur
il y a très peu de femmes qui qui sont
éditeurs éditrices pour Wikipédia et ça
a un effet sur ce qui a été écrit euh
c'est un fait qu'on a couvert dans un
livre que j'ai édité qui s'appelle
Barbie to mortal combat gender and
computer games Barbie tout mortal combat
par que c'est la même chose en français
on dit mortal combat combat mortel ouais
tout Barbie Mortal Kombat gender and
computer game
le genre et les jeux vidéos d'accord
c'est un livre qu'on a publié en 2000 et
qui est à son è édition ça continue
d'être édité parce que malheureusement
c'est toujours les mêmes problèmes donc
sur l'empoisonnement des données sur
l'empoisonnement de tout ça vas-y
Cédric tout est empoisonné ou
empoisonnable dans le temps si je dis
pas de bêtises ouais ils avaient été
piraté par le piraté par des équipes
chinoises
euh système GPS aussi d'ailleurs système
GPS je savais pas mais tout pour la
localisation des bateaux des fois tu
fais débarquer des bateaux ils sont pas
à la bonne place ah ça pe ça c'est ça
c'est c'est fortique tout est piraté
tout est piratable et le la quantité de
cyberattaque qu'on trouve partout dans
le monde c'est truc phénoménal et tu
parlais de poison quand tu te retrouves
infecté par un rang somware on dit que
le temps moyen que le ran somware reste
dormant dans ton système avant de se
manifester c'est de l'ordre de 200 jours
il reste là à bien s'incruster dans le
système à à s'infiltrer un peu partout
et le le c'est une activité noire qui
est en augmentation exponentielle mais
il y a quelque chose que je comprends
pas très bien Bertrand quand tu dis
est-ce que SK comment i c'est Sky ah Sky
est-ce que
euh quand tu dis quand tu demandes
est-ce que les gouvernements peut
empoison ou des gouvernements ou des
DESS pe empoisonner
quoi empoisonner la façon dont la donnée
non empoisonner la façon don dont la
donnée est assimilée
euh
alors réponse
technique il est enfin pour la plupart
lorsqu'on
utilise des systèmes comme JPT 3,5 ou
gpt4 pour une fin donnée on fait ce qui
s'appelle F to
je l'ai fait dans mon labo avec mes
doctorants fine tuning ça veut dire
qu'on prend le système neutre et on lui
donne nos propres données pour l'affiner
dans un sens ou dans un autre bon moi ce
qui m'intéresse j'ai un projet avec un
doctorant qui s'appelle bisw mapatra qui
fait un travail hyper intéressant sur le
fait que ces systèmes ne prennent pas en
compte
l'interlocuteur il parl pour parler ils
essaient de se garder en ligne aussi
longtemps que possible la vérité ne joue
pas de rôle et le fait que tu comprends
toi interlocuteur ou que tu comprends
pas ne joue aucun rôle alors est-ce que
nous pouvons apprendre à ces machines à
demander tu as compris ou je te donne
davantage de détail à une personne qui a
l'air de ne pas suivre et on le fait en
faisant du fine tuning c'est-à-dire
qu'on lui donne des exemples de ce que
c'est que ce qui s'appelle en
linguistique conversational grounding
c'est-à-dire euh vérifier l'état de
connaissance de la personne avec qui on
parle avant qu'on qu'on continue à toute
vitesse avec sa conversation donc fine
tuning est un moyen de changer la donne
de prendre un
système énorme qui a été formé sur des
milliards de données et lui permettre ou
le forcer à agir d'une façon donnée et
donc ça c'est possible c'est un moyen
d'empoisonnement aussi bien qu'un moyen
d'amélioration question Internet est-ce
qu'ils peuvent nous expliquer les vertus
et les dangers des données
synthétiques pour les entraînements des
modèles données synthétiques sujet oui
euh alors c'est je pense que c'est une
question technique euh
ces modèles ces types d'apprentissage
automatique demandent énormément de
données moi je veux former des machines
qui euh prennent en compte la relation
avec l'interlocuteur qui ne te parle pas
de la même façon demain que d'ici 2
semaines c'est une partie de mon travail
tu travailles sur des bottes sexuel non
d'accord tuon connais qui travaille sur
ça euh j'en ai croisé oui oui oui il y a
une conférence làdessus l'état
psychologique de ces gens c'est pour
faire du blé c'est
pour permettre au petits japonais de
d'être moins seul c'est c'est quoi
l'objectif de faire ça sais pas mais on
parle loin des données synthétiques
d'accord je vais terminer avec les
données synthétiques d'accord non c'est
pas grave enfin c'est juste pour
répondre à la question donc puis que il
n'existe pas de milliards de données sur
les interactions entre les personnes on
prend
une petite base de données et on le
réplique on en forme des données
synthétiques qui ressemblent aux données
qu'on a parce qu'on a peu de données
voilà donc ça c'est la la réponse
technique il y a un avantage qui est
dans le fait d'avoir beaucoup de données
qui permettent de de faire
l'entraînement il y a un autre avantage
des fois pour des quand on a des données
sensibles c'est d'éviter utiliser des
vrais données par exemple données de
santé ou autrre mais à la place
d'utiliser des données de de personnes
qui existent pas qui sont des
utilisateurs imaginair
et et et dans un contexte où tout est
piratable c'est appréciable il il y a
quelques années une chercheuse en
spécialiste en donné la Tania SNE avait
pour montrer que les données de santé
étaient pas soi-disant anonymisé qui
étaaiit dans lesadministration
américaine ne l'était pas s'était amusé
avec son équipe à réidentifier le
dossier du gouverneur du massachuss pour
bien montrer voyez sécuriser mon œil bon
et donc alors tuas
bléoragie et alors utiliser c'est pas ta
femme les données synthétiques permet
aussi de d'éviter de manipuler c'est
c'est c'est vrais données et ça ça peut
être c'est quelque chose qui qui qui
peut être intéressant un exemple de
données synthétique intéressant c'était
ce site Web comment c'est this person is
not real ou quelque chose comme ça ù
quand on le on le tape à chaque fois ça
affiche une personne différente qui est
intéressante très réaliste mais qui
n'existe pas évidemment on pourrait
utiliser des des des entraînements des
an nottion à partir de ces de toutes ces
personnes qui n'existent pas mais sont
pourtant de quoi faire une grande base
de données entraîner des algorithmes à
partir de là revenons à nos botes
sexuelles oui voilà alors il y a une
conférence qui s'appelle je pense sex
and love robots donc évidemment c'est le
sujet de toute la conférence moi j'ai
jamais assisté ça m'intéresse pas mais
bah parce que c'est pas un sujet qui
m'intéresse je trouve que c'est sans oui
c'est sans intérêt du point vue
scientifique et euh il y a des gens pour
qui c'est important et positif d'avoir
des Sex And Love robots ça peut servir
de marche-pied à des relations avec
d'autres personnes et il y a des
personnes pour qui c'est un un piss
enfin c'est un un une rue où il y a pas
de sortie une impasse oui merci une
impasse mais la personne qui a fondé
cette conférence si je comprends bien
son parcours c'est quelqu'un qui aime
épaté les bourgeois et c'est pour ça
qu'il le fait quoi épaté les bourgeois
ah ben je pensais que c'était une bonne
phrase française épaté les bourgeois ça
veut dire de faire quelque chose on le
dit en anglais d'ailleurs on dit épat
les bois
ouais en français dans le texte
c'est-à-dire de faire quelque chose
pour la galerie non pas la galerie pour
euh faire de la peine aux bourgeois
faire de la peine aux riches faire de la
peine au au au aux gens bien pensants
voilà choqué oui voilà épaté les
bourgeois c'est choqué ok je viens
d'apendre quelque chose je vais regarder
après pour être sûr que je suis pas TR
tu m'empoisonnerais la donnée c'est ça
oui voilà je veux pas t'empoisonner tes
donné
j'utilise l'exemple de de Justine comme
marche-pied vers pour mettre un vrai
problème de société qu'il faut regarder
en face dans une époque d'hyper
commmunication qui est le grand le le le
plus grand changement de comportement de
la dernière génération c'est le fait que
ça communique tous les imutes et dans
une époque où les
activités sexuelles en ligne se
multiplie on assiste à ce que les gens
appellent une épidémie de solitude à une
raréfaction mesurée claire dans le monde
occidental particulièrement aux
États-Unis de du nombre de d'amis
proches et à une rare faaction de la
sexualité physique quelque chose qui
interroge pas une petite pognette non
moi je te dis que nous disent les
sociologues question internet
intelligence artificielle plus les
machines de Boston dynamique ça va faire
un mal à quel
point machine de Boston Dynamics je suis
pas un spécialiste mais de parce que
évidemment chaque fois qu'on a que que
que les les médias veulent illustrer l'a
très souvent ils vont mettre les
machines de Boston dynamic 1 il y a une
certaine opacité entretenue sur leur sur
la façon dont il fonctionne de c'est pas
de Lia c'est des techniques de
d'optimisation de il faut regarder non
pas les vidéos courtes mais les vidéos
longues où le robot tombe sur son visage
n'arrive pas à rester visage le robot
euh il y en a qui ont des visages enfin
le robot chien il a quelques temps il y
a quelques temps un journaliste connu et
respecté avait partagé sur sur Twitter
mais comme d'autres à l'époque qui s'app
encore Twitter des images d'entraînement
de ces robots style Boston
Dynamics on voyait bien quandand on
connaissait quand on avait bossé un
petit peu le sujet que c'était un un
fake que c'était des que c'était pas que
c'est des images de synthèse pas les
vrais robots les robots sont pas du tout
au niveau qu'on voit sur les vidéos mais
ça n'empêchait pas l'information de se
propager de façon virale il y a une
grosse hype qui est faite autour de ces
robots et et pour l'instant même les les
mari le le savoir-faire universitaire
habituel en robotique et savoir-faire
universitaire en intelligence
artificielle c'est des des des
programmes de recherche qui sont très
loin d'être d'être mature question
Internet les humains irrationnels
excessifs vivant en somme ne risqu-t-ils
pas d'être perçu comme des problèmes par
des gestions publiques déléguées à des
IA c'est quoi les gestion publique
déléguées à desa lesésent vois quand tu
vois une une caméah d'un fournisseur
chinois équipé d'une intelligence
artificielle et
d'un d'un algo de détection du mouvement
de foule de concentration si c'est des
terroristes pas des terroristes sils
sont agglomérés au même point pendant 2
minutes 30 ça peut être
problématique moi qui marche à
clochepied et à la marelle dans les rues
pour me déplacer est-ce que je toi aussi
non toi c'est les escaliers tu les Mones
ouis moi je monre lesescalier est-ce que
je vais pas être perçu comme un un un
problème c'est une question oou c'est la
finesse qui compte on voit des pays dans
lequel dans lesquels ça existe ou euh et
ben on souhaide on a une expression
euh le clou qui dépasse est martelé euh
c'est une expression qui dit beaucoup en
Chine on a une expression qui veut dire
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
que c'est mieux si on rentre dans le
chemin de tout le monde donc on voit des
exemples et en général nous en en en
luttant contre je je je rebondis c'est
très intéressant ce que tu viens de dire
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que lia va pas
faire un immense élevage de poulet
humain
standardiser les les
gens bah non parce que enfin encore une
fois l'utilisation du mot I
pourrait être remplacé par numérique
ou par être humain pas bon pour nous
enfin des mauvais des malfaiteurs c'est
c'est pas lias ça c'est n'importe enfin
tout tu sais que je fais exprès de faire
ça pour que tu expliques comment je fais
exprès pour que tu expliques d'accord ok
mais une chose que li a permet en fait
c'est énormément de catégories justement
il a de nos jours on n'a pas besoin de
de neutraliser les différences parce que
il est capable de travailler en
parallèle à des centaines de
catégories donc ça c'est une réponse et
je pense que c'est pas la réponse que tu
voulais qui est-ce qui voulait une
réponse ici comment qui voulait une
réponse les les auditeurs veulent une
réponse alors on va leur dire on va dire
aux auditeur explicitement il y a plein
de gens dont c'est le but dans ce
domaine que d'alimenter les peurs et de
faire le maximum de buzz qui des
criminels comme Elon Musk ah
non mus pourquoi tu dis
criminel parce que on a là quelqu'un qui
alors criminel au sens figuré je dis pas
qu'il a tué des gens mais on a là
quelqu'un
qui d'abord dans quelques domaines qui
touche cherche à aller vers la solution
la plus anti olique possible qui met en
place des systèmes avec le le le d'une
inégalité extraordinaire qui dérégulent
des systèmes déjà dérégulés qui prend en
main on a David chavalrias vous montre
bien aussi avec mesure à l'appui que
depuis la reprise en main X est devenu
une machine à désinformer bien plus
forte que ce que c'était avant et à et à
climatoignalé et tout ça c'est-à-dire
c'est-à-dire que on a un système X qui
aujourd'hui est encore plus
polarisé dans laquelle se propage les
est-ce que tu as lu les Twitter files
non qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que
c'est les Twitter files l ça et puis tu
m'appelles et puis on refait une
émission làdessus d'accord on va en
parler mais ce que je te dis là c'est
des choses mesurées par les collègues
spécialistes de mesure de l'information
sur réseau sociaux les Twitter files il
a un autre truc qui est en train de
sortir c'est les contrô files ou c'est
TRL files un truc comme ça il question
internet al juste avant termine le le il
y a pas longtemps le scientifique en
chef de open a disait en tout cas c'est
comme ça que les journaux l'ont l'ont
repris qu'il craignait le jour où une
intelligence artificielle générale nous
traiterait comme des animaux c'est ça
bon ce qui est de la science-fiction
peut-être un jour ça se passera mais
pour l'instant c'est science-fiction et
c'est pas les petits algorithmes qu'on a
aujourd'hui si impressionnant sur les
résultats qui vont faire ça bon mais
quand quelqu'un de ce niveau alimente ça
c'est très clairement de façon cynique
pour avoir le plus grand buzz possible
attirer par le scandale l'appétit des
médias et l'appétit des investisseurs et
et et les réponses à ce genre de truc
comme les réponses au poisons comme les
réponses à aux manipulations et autres
c'est pas dans la régulation supérieure
c'est arrêter de fantasmer c'est dans la
PS arrz de fantasmer dans la psychologie
mais aussi les ressources humaines le
fait d'avoir des des gens pour pour agir
programmer contrôler et cetera et cetera
des gens plutôt que des plutôt que des
règles mais pour les fantasmes passe
notre temps en tout cas sans arrêt les
questions dire genre est-ce que Lya va
faire ceci est-ce que l va faire cela on
est dans un monde où il y a plein de
pays où on se fait pendre pour un tweet
mal placé c'est ça arrive en Arabie
Saoudite tu es parce qu'on est
albinos parce qu'on est étudiant ça ça
ça ou pas il y a il y a un massacre
massacre d'étudiants qui se produit en
Iran my qui était élu en Argentine
peut-être Trump bientôt qui va renir je
veux dire les nouvelles du monde
physique humain aujourd'hui sont
tellement inquiétantes sans y sans ya et
quand franchement ça me fait plus peur
que les possibilités de l'a ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on voit arri aujourdhui quand
quand unea aide un gouvernement à cibler
des cibles au sol l'armée israélienne
utilise une IA pour
cibler c'est vraiment oxyogène ça pour
vous c'est normal c'est la la la juste
continuité de la science et des choses
c'est pas lia enfin ça se fait
depuis depuis toujours on cible
l'ennemi est-ce que avoir des meilleurs
moyens de le faire veut dire que tout
d'un coup c'est devenu horrible je suis
pas d'accord parce que je trouve que
c'est si a si on pas Solomon est-ce que
la la la liya est responsable devant un
tribunal de guerre non non ça n pas de
sens c'est le mec qui a entraîné liya
qui est responsable c'est c'est le mec
qui appuie sur le bouton c'est qui c'est
le mec c'est le
politique Politi responsable c'est par
définition c'est lui qui doit être
responsable traduit dev la Cour de
justice Cour pénale internationale ou ce
que tu veux mais c'est le politique qui
doit être responsable c'est
l'utilisation et pas lia il faut qu'on
arrête de parler dia parce que je pense
que même ici
en question internet non je termine
juste même ici sur surtout ici où tu as
tellement de personnes qui qui
t'écoutent il il faut leur apprendre que
lia veut rien dire la phrase deux
personnes qui t'écoutent les deux
personnes qui nous écoutent il faut leur
dire à tous
deux que ça veut rien dire il y a
intelligence artificielle faut parler de
façon
plus
exacte non c'est même plus les raisons
enfin si c'est des réseaux de neurones
mais
pour les personnes qui sont pas
techniques ça non plus ça n'a pas de
sens vas-y continue tu m'autorises oui
je
t'autorise ou je sais je suis génreuse
mais pas pendant longtemps donc vas-y
c'est vrai des menaces tout de suite
d'après vous question internet d'après
vous à quel point sommes-nous proches de
la
singularité très très très loin
singularité c'est encore du du de la
science fiction
ouais c'est du fantasme pensez-vous quea
va révolutionner ou résoudre les
problématiques physiques mathématiques
et les préoccupation
humaine a tellement comme ça là alors
est-ce que est-ce que c'est ça qui va
sauver le monde la réponse est NON je
veux dire est-ce c'est une nouvelle
religion non mais le
technosolutionnisme est une est une
forme de religion qui contribue à nous
emmener dans le mur ouis tout autant que
le techno n c'est les amiches oui c'est
c'est l'opposé du ah ben attends les
amis si nous embête pas ils sont non non
franchement il ils nous font aucun mal
le laboratoire C initié par Xavier Niel
est-il une réponse à une forme de souver
souverainisme numérique ou un cheval de
TR moi j'aime bien le projet j'aime bien
la façon dont ça a été présenté j'aime
bien la façon l'idée de mettre en avant
de pousser des acteurs européens et le
fait de de parier sur de l'Open Source
autant que possible pour rappel il y a
pas
longtemps yen Lequin qui est l'une des
plus grandes superstar imaginables en
matière de d'intelligence artificielle
et celui qui a le plus contribué à
remettre les réseaux de neurones dans le
dans dans l'image là où on les avait
tout le monde n presque les avait mis de
côté Yan Lequin estimait il y a pas
longtemps que en quelques années les mod
de les grands modèles
génératifs en open source en mode ouvert
serait bien plus performant que les
modèles privés que ce soit celui de open
ou celui de Google ouais de même pour
les petits modèles vis-à-vis des grands
modèles parce que trèsfin nous
chercheurs on veut pas devenir
consommateur de de travail
d'autrui on veut pas devenir
consommateur de travail qui qui bousie
le climat et donc vraiment je pense que
l'avenir c'est les petits les petits
modèles remarque tout à l'heure tu
parlais des des supervisions et du
renforcement humain oui en l'occurrence
pour chadpt c'était des travailleurs kan
payés à 2 dollars de l'heure donc dans
des condition et puis des horaires
impossibles des conditions proches de
l'esclavage je suis curiux de savoir si
le lia de de Google la dernière a été ah
c'est une bonne question oui oui Bard tu
veux dire B Jini Jini a été a été elle
entraîné
et c'est non seulement enfin bon c'est
les kéiens qui ont fait la supervision
humaine de ces de ces logiciels c'est
aussi des gens souvent en Afrique qui
font la modération de Facebook et qui
peuvent pas le faire pendant très
longtemps parce que ce qui voit est
tellement abominable qu'il font un
burnout presque immédiat des des des
PTSD des des syndromes posttraumatiques
imaginez-nous ce qu'on voit
bah quand les IAS seront capables de
faire des maths à un tel niveau
qu'aucune cryptographie pourra tenir à
une attaque qu'adeviendra-t-il du
système financier et
militaire point à la ligne
pointinrogation
ah il y a partout des certes il y a
partout des attaques pour l'instant il y
a des grands jeux d'attaque et de
contre-attaque un peu partout c'est même
fascinant de voir ça
euh on parlait des images et des
modérations sur Facebook dans le temps
quand quand il y avait eu l'attentat de
Christ Church en Nouvelle-Zélande les
terroristes ont balancé sur les réseaux
sociaux ce jour-là ce jour-là la vidéo a
été mise en ligne à peu près un million
de fois et automatiquement retiré un
million de fois par les algorithmes de
détection donc tu as de l'attaque de la
contre-attaque en même temps du point de
vue de l'humanité c'est fascinant de
voir l'énergie phénoménale qui est
dépensée en quelque chose qui sanî mais
quand tu auras des IA très très fortes
pour pirater tu auras aussi des IAS qui
seront entraîné très très fortement pour
défendre et ça sera un jeu de de
gendarmes et de voleurs de cache-cache
si on veut je voudrais dire un truc par
rapport à à mathématique
euh pour l'instant il y a pas eu de
révolution en mathématique avec lia je
veux dire le ça il y a certaines preuves
aidées par ordinateur qui sont fait avec
des explorations depuis la fameuse
preuve du théorème des quatre couleurs
par Apple et Aken en 1976 un truc qui a
fait date dans la communauté
mathématique ou plus récemment la preuve
de l'empilement l'opilement optimal des
sphères l'empilement de Kepler par Tom
HES mais il y a pas eu de révolution li
à l'IA en mathématique en revanche il y
a eu des progrès impressionnants de l en
médecine certainement le domaine dans
lequel il y a plus d'applications
scientifiqu impressionnantes avec des
outils diagnosti des outils de contrôle
de procédure qui sont impressionnants et
qui font mieux que les meilleurs humains
dans dans un certain nombre de cas il y
a eu en biologie question
comm la prédiction de la forme la forme
des protéines il y a eu en chimie sur
les 4 dernières années des progrès très
impressionnants di faisant des
propositions nouvelles structures de
nouvelles molécules de de nouveaux
réseaux qui change la donne tout à
l'heure tu nous as posé une question sur
la normalisation de la population par
lia est-ce que alors vous savez qu'on
est sur une planète de poulet by the way
le poulet il a bien plus de ou que
d'humain sur cette planète et le
l'élevage représente 60 % de la de la
biomasse terrestre non mais c'est un
truc de fou j'allais dire que en santé
une des choses que les algorithmes
peuvent faire que les médecins peuvent
pas faire et qui vraiment avance la
médecine d'une façon incroyable c'est la
catégorisation par millions c'est-à-dire
que chaque personne peut être une
catégorie on peut trouver une solu à une
maladie dont souffre une seule personne
donc c'est pas que la normalisation
c'est pas forcément la normalisation
justement parce que ces algorithmes
peuvent tenir en parallèle tellement de
catégories question internet alors on va
prendre en considérant l'événement d'une
agi ou super agi c'est quoi leur c'est
quoi leur prototopie d'un monde
post-travail alors attends ici
prmise ici il y a marqué Cédric Villani
je veux dire mathématicien scientifique
essaie de garder sa raison il y a pas
écrit Arthur Clark ou ou Isa kimov je
suis pas un auteur de science-fiction il
faut poser la question un auteur de
science-fiction sur les agi c'est de là
que ça relève on n'est pas des
futuristes et l'agi c'est c'est une
future possible je pense très peu
probable
qui general intelligence c'est quoi la a
artifici ah oui artificial general
intelligence donc l'intelligence
artificielle générale qui peut faire
tout ce que peut faire un humain je
pense
pas jamais on peut pas aimer quand on t
une intelligence artificielle c'est ça
bah il y a plein de choses qu'on peut
pas faire non mais une intelligence
artificielle pour l'instant c'est une
formule mathématique sophistiquée ça a
ni plus ni moins d'émotion que la
recette de calcul des impôts elle est un
peu plus sophistiquée certes mais c'est
une for formu de ma le réseau de neurone
oui question plus simple et facile à
répondre est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle peut-elle devenir marxiste
et intégrer la lutte des classes dans
son algorithme la réponse oui bien sûr
et inversement comment inversement
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle peut devenir
autre chose que marxiste moracienne bah
oui bien sûr suffit de lui faire manger
l'auteur qu'on veut voilà d'ailleurs
quand quand quand Microsoft avait sorti
son agent conversationnel son bot il y a
quelques années teille en a un rien de
temps des petits malins c'était occupés
de lui laver le Cau entre guillemets de
sorte qu'il était devenu fasciste
trumpiste matchiste et tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer ouais ouais ça c'est le
fine t c'est qui le plus fort c'est
Batman ou Parker
Lewis ça arrêté au oui là ils ont fumé
ils ont la Christian et Christiana tu ne
fumes pas tu regardes les temps alors
Batman Batman euh est un de
mes grands héros comme on sait Batman
est le super-héros sans super pouvoir ce
qui le rend particulièrement intéressant
et c'est l'un des tu dis il a un super
pouvoir il est pété de fric oui alors il
est il est il est super intelligent et
super riche absolument mais il n'a pas
de super pouvoir enfin au sens habituel
maintenant il représente bien pour moi
Batman c'est une une des incarnations de
la science en tant que aussi projet les
grands projets technologi qui ont besoin
de qui ont besoin de d'argent pour se
réaliser Batman et docteur Manhattan
pour moi c'est les deux les deux grandes
incarnations en BD de de la science en
tant que alors maintenant on arrive aux
choses importantes tuas bon alors
parlons de la recette du
pigeon avec plaisir est-ce que vous
voulez parler d'un truc dont on n pas
parlé
oui il y a
un
débat il y a des débats scientifiques
majeurs encore à trouver dans
lia premièrement le fait que les progrès
de Lia ont surpris tout le
monde quand les réseaux de neurones sont
devenus très performant vers 2012 et
d'un coup on a vu paf c'est bien bien
meilleur que ce qu'on croyait quand sont
arrivés les modèles d'intelligence
artificielle générative il y a un an et
quelques
et si c'est est devenu aussi fort il y a
forcément une raison derrière théorique
ça nous renseigne sur le fait que notre
compréhension algorithmique de ces
processus d'apprentissage est très
mauvaise actuellement
embryonnaire on a un savoir pragmatique
en quête de théorie il y a d'autres
moments dans notre histoire scientifique
où on avait une théorie en quête
d'application un exemple que j'aime bien
c'est qu' en 1948 Claude Shannon publie
sa théorie de la communication un
monstre qui lance la théorie de
l'information il démontre
mathématiquement qu'il existe des codes
hyper efficaces qui compriment les
messages sans perdre d'information au
taux optimal ou presque qui est défini
en fonction de l'entropie du langage
mais il a fallu 50 ans avant qu'on
trouve les algorithmes qui réalisent
cette prédiction théorique de Shannon
aujourd'hui on est dans une sitation
renversée par rapport à ça c'est-à-dire
qu'on a des algorithmes très efficaces
mais on sait pas quelle prédiction il
réalise on na pas la théorie ouais le
fait qui avait pas été
anticipé par les auteurs de
science-fiction qu'on puisse avoir desas
qui aujourd'hui fassent des tâches aussi
subtiles sans la moindre 11
intelligence sans aucune intelligence
artificiel général c'était pas anticipé
un dit quelque chose sur la convergence
algorithmique de ces modèles qui est
bien plus rapide que prévu on sait pas
l'expliquer c'est un défi scientifique
passionnant de ça dit quelque chose sur
structure des des textes et du savoir
tel qu'il est organisé le fait qu'on
puisse écrire des lettres aussi fines et
subtil que ce que font les chatgpt ou
autre
c'est ça veut dire qu'il y a quelque
chose des régularités dans les ledes
dans notre expression bien plus forte
que ce que ce qu'on croyait j oui ça
c'est très joli ce que Cédric vient de
dire moi je me frotte les mains quand
j'entends ça ouiah oui parce que tu sais
cette régularité plus c'est régulé tu
moi plus plus plus il y a une régularité
plus tu peux hacker absolument mais
c'est ça que que que que la technologie
est en train de faire
ouais mais si je je regarde le revers de
la pièce qui est que ces régularités
nous enseignent sur nous-mêmes aussi
absolument et c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose ça nous enseigne sur nos
manières de penser nos manières d'
écrire ces régularités existent en nos
textes parce que nous sommes humains et
que ces machines ont capté quelque chose
qui nous rend humain faut pas l'oublier
c'est pas le contraire ça nous rend pas
machines c'est nous qui rendons ces
machines comme nous
aussi j'espère que on va pas rendre les
machines aussi bêt que nous
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour faire
libérer à Sange
beaucoup de bruit c'est un problème
purement politique évidemment il y a un
débat un problème juridique monstrueux
avec des avocats internationaux de tous
les côtés des appels contreappel et tout
ça mais le le vrai problème le fond du
fond il est évidemment politique Assange
est un prisonnier politique et donc et
et l'angl ça se résout par ça se résout
par de la pression politique la il y a
eu plein de mauvaises nouvelles pour
Assange dernières années mais il y a a
quelques bonnes nouvelles première bonne
nouvelle l'opinion australienne est
maintenant résolument pour lui pour son
retour au pays pour l'extirpé des
griffes américaines d'abord les griffes
anglaises ici la la Grande-Bretagne qui
a vraiment un rôle abominable dans
l'histoire d'abord à menti de la façon
la plus hontée le gouvernement anglais
chaque fois qu' s'exprime sur Assange
c'est un mensonge honté qu'on peut
prouver pour être un un mensonge compl
sur l'IRAC aussi ça marche he oui on se
souvient 2003 Tony Blair et tout ça mais
le la Grande-Bretagne là c'est juste je
vais employer un mot dur a juste été le
larbin des États-Unis
là-dessus et la question c'est la la
pression sur le alors la pression sur le
gouvernement surt le gouvernement sur le
gouvernement britannique sur le
gouvernement américain sur les autres
gouvernements en tant qu'il peuvent
mettre de la pression les le la
population australienne et la classe
politique australienne maintenant aussi
bien l'opposition que la que la majorité
sont en faveur d'Assange ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle dans un contexte de
tension géopolitique accrue les
Américains peuvent pas juste balayer du
revers de la main un allié comme
l'Australie surtout en Australie qui est
proche de la Chine et cetera et cetera
bon ils fend des sous-marins en plus et
en plus il y a les fameux sous-marins
absolument deuxè chose un petit signal
mais qui indique y a un frémissement
quelque part il y a quelques
semaines les
quelques députés américains des
démocrate et même de l' gauche démocrate
des gens comme aosé Alexandra ocasio CZ
corz et des députés républicains et même
de l'aile droite républicains des hyper
Trump se sont allié dans une déclaration
transpartisan rare cétait je sais pas
peut-être une quinzaine une petite
minorité de députés en soutien d'Assange
petite minorité mais quand même le fait
qu'il a ce truc bipartisan qui était
inimaginable il y a seulement il y a
encore un ou 2 ans montre qu'il y a un
petit frémissement donc pour Assange il
faut continuer là-dessus mettre la
pression à tous les niveau hein ça veut
dire sur votre député sur les ministres
sur qui sait quoi sur les réseaux free
Julian Assange now c'est l'un des c'est
le slogan sur les sur les réseaux euh le
plus de bruit il y aura là-dessus le
plus il y aura des messages simples du
genre avoir un prisonnier politique dans
les démocraties occidentales sur un
sujet de la presse au moment où on où il
y a toutes ces tension géopolitique
c'est un message politique calamiteux
désastreux ça nous décédibilise ça nous
affaiblit et et il faut marteler ce
genre de message jusqu'à ce que le le
plus de pression se fasse Justine tu
veux ajouter un mot là-dessus non
je est-ce que tu as trois livres à nous
conseiller alors oui oui fait de
l'intelligence
artificielle alors j'arrive pas à me
rappeler du nom de l'auteur the diamond
age c'est on va trouver ça tout de suite
un livre de
science-fiction que
j'adore qui date maintenant d'il y a au
moins 20 ans qui parle d'une d'unea qui
accompagne une jeune femme à travers sa
vie donc j'aime beaucoup ce
livre je vais m'arrêter tiens on va
faire alors Kali Hunter comment Hunter
Kali Kali Hunter non non c'est pas
ça Diamond age c'est un un é
science-fiction très renommé bon d'abord
on a parlé tout à l'heure mais on va
rappeler explicitement deux pour moi de
deux ouvrages qui sont des des
classiques et importants c'est l'ouvrage
de Cathy oil sur algorithme la bombe à
retardement qui décrit bien desbis un
certain nombre de catastrophes déjà
produit dans un certain nombre
d'administrations par l'usage de Lia mal
encadré ou mal développé et de toxidcta
de David chavalaria ce qui est le
meilleur exposé que j'ai vu récemment
sur les questions informationnelles je
vais ajouter une petite bande dessinée
de de Laurent doudé avec un dessinateur
indien qui s'appelle appupen si je dis
pas de bêtises la bande dessinée doit
s'appeler Dream machine ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est une bande dessinée très
pédagogique sur ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle et sur ses possibles dérive
et en particulier la possibilité pour
des intérêts euh privés extrêmement
puissants de s'en emparer et d'utiliser
pour un projet qui soit un projet non
seulement économique mais politique euh
avec des visées importantes sur les
libertés des des citoyen mais l'ouvrage
est très pédagogique sur ce que c'est
que l'intelligence artificielle
l'entraînement ainsi de suite tu
conseilles pas le livre de Laurent
Alexandre je conseille de le brûler mais
on brûle pas des
livres et qu'est-ce que tu en pens
vraiment bon non non c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'il faut pas brûler les livres tu
as raison il est il est important de en
vrai de la même façon non je vais te
répondre plus hnêtement de la même façon
que dans ma bibliothèque j'ai aussi des
bouquins de climactodéignaliste rien que
pour savoir quelle est l'argumentation
et des bouquins du lobby des voiture
pour savoir quelle est leur
argumentation il faut toujours savoir ce
que dit l'adversaire ou l'irrationnel
pour bâtir le discours par-dessus donc
effectivement retire ce que j'ai brûle
ce que j'ai dit sur sur le livre à
brûler c'est bien de l'avoir pour avoir
la la voix du la voix du fou furieux en
la matière il pas fou furieux il a un
point de vue différent bon euh toi tu es
je vois que tu n'es que amour et c'est
bien
ah je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là
comment tuas pas d'autres bouquins
est-ce que est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes génér
de livre non un conseil pour les jeunes
générations conseil oui euh tu vas pas
casser ces machines il faut jouer avec
il faut pas avoir peur il faut les
traiter comme des outils parce que ce
sont des outils et c'est toi maître
maîtresse c'est toi qui va en faire
quelque chose de bien ou de mauvais donc
efforce-toi d'apprendre de comprendre et
de faire du
bien jouer avec très important liya est
un sujet pragmatique de bout en bout les
chercheurs développent de façon
pragmatique les les citoyens peuvent
s'amuser avec jouer avec c'est un sujet
que tout le monde doit SAP proprié
discuter en ce moment à Montpel a une
expérience fort intéressante de
convention citoyenne sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui a été mise en place par
le maire président de la métropole de
Montpellier et et qui sont des citoyens
tirés au sort même tirage sort mais où
on a exclu les experts en en numérique
et qui reçoivent des formations comme
dans les conventions citoyennne
d'habitude donc j'étais en tant
que conférencier invité dans la dans la
séance de d'installation et c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement intéressant
aussi pour permettre aux politiques aux
citoyens de s'approprier le sujet à
travers une sorte de feuille de route
ouais c'est ça le bon verbe s'approprier
ses outils point
empowerment c'est ça empowerment oui en
capacitisation en capacitation oui euh
un conseil pour les jeunes génération
Cédric euh bon moi quand on demande des
conseils pour les jeunes générations
d'habitude je donne toujours les mêmes
les les trois quatre mêmes
euh
de éviter les l'enfermement dans les
cases fixées à priori je leur conseille
de bouger régulièrement quand un quand
on maîtrise un sujet c'est le moment de
regarder le sujet d'à côté sans renier
le sujet qu'on a maîtriser mais
commencer à regarder les sujet d'à côté
très important je conseille pour très
important je conseille aux jeunes de
laisser une part de hasard dans dans ce
qui va guider leur parcours le hasard
nous amène à explorer des choses qu'on
aurait auquel on aaurait jamais pensé de
Diamond age c'est de Nils Nils Stevenson
bien sûr oui c'est ça ouais Justine
Cédric
merci merci à toi merci à toi
[Musique]